this show is brought to you by onyx.com
go to onit.com and use codeword church
to save 10 on all of their amazing
optimization products like alpha brain
new mood trim tech immune and shroom
tech sport on it.com code word church
oh [ __ ]
september 26 monday
the church of what's happening now
this is what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
a train running up your [ __ ] spine
[ __ ] suckers
you know how many times listen to this
song in the dark
yeah how many
you know how many times i listen to the
song in the dark
crying
it scared the [ __ ] out of me
but it made me a [ __ ] madman and [ __ ]
chicken chicken
[ __ ] tremendous scott suckers
are you kidding me or what
coming out the jump tonight [ __ ]
the church what's happening now
my little brother lee cyan hello my main
man george perez doing the podcast
[ __ ] circuit lately hell yeah what's
up doggy dog nothing dog these
[ __ ] show up lately you know
what i'm saying
these [ __ ] don't know we've
been running since [ __ ]
piazzo yeah the mug [ __ ] montoya to
make sure you had cash
yeah i tell people go man i'm so blessed
i met you like nine months in the game
and you just grabbed me you're like come
here dog let's do this [ __ ] yeah you had
a heart in the beginning these guys show
up you know with a suitcase
you showed up with the truck the piano
and you said [ __ ] it i'm all in that's
it yeah and you wanted weed yeah you got
some weeds [ __ ] you always
you got to show up with something
nothing is free you know what i'm saying
right now we
what was that thing from the 70s grass
as a gas
nobody rides for free remember people
just put on their bumper stickers this
[ __ ] that was a bumper stick really i
never saw it no you were [ __ ] uh an
inch in your daddy's pants and that
bumper sticker was popular today i went
to the doctor and he had a smiley face
that's from the [ __ ] 70s a smiley
face smiley face that little [ __ ]
thing yeah don't worry be happy yeah
that thing started in like 74 73 some
guy was in his [ __ ] office dooley
when you doodle what do you mean dude
when you're sitting here on a pen and
i'm talking about like writing [ __ ]
little ants and [ __ ] bugs with hairs
and [ __ ] on them
you ever see that [ __ ] when you finish
the conversation look at the pattern in
front of you you got numbers on there
like you're gonna remember under this
[ __ ] you're taking numbers and addresses
then you rip that [ __ ] thing up you
throw it away
there goes the [ __ ] party you don't
want to call him back i just have weird
shapes
i look like a crazy person and someone
ever went through my mail yeah that's it
you're just [ __ ] talking to your mom
and you're just [ __ ] scribbling the
thing you know maybe he says something
i'm weird like i do like old graffiti
that i used to write so like i do like i
try to do my name like in the old
gangster style a lot and i don't know
it's weird i always do like perez perez
proud of it you know i ain't mad at you
you got perez on your back i got perez
on my stomach i got it on my arm four
times for all my kids [ __ ] it
perez perez perez if tony tony tony did
it you could do it too
[ __ ] this [ __ ] good to see you
though oh yeah
still making the [ __ ] happen
trying you know i tell people that the
experience that you have here sometimes
you sit back some nights and you see
people who disappeared
they just disappear you know your dad
was in jiu jitsu and i turned around i
go you know what that's a complete
different fundamental class
i don't even know these be like turnover
is big
but it's even bigger when you come here
and you start out with guys for three or
four months then one day oh they got a
day job why
why did you get a day job you were doing
great they didn't have the heart attack
to hustle i don't know no well it's like
listen everybody has the heart to get on
stage the first three times
is the hardest thing you'll ever [ __ ]
do in your life that's the hardest thing
you'll ever do in your life once you do
the first three times
you're in you might not be [ __ ]
kicking ass or you might not be johnny
carson
but you're in but it's like anything
else when you bartend
the first two shifts you're [ __ ]
putting club soda and the [ __ ]
rockets and orange juices
you don't think anything else and then
you develop the [ __ ] things then you
develop the speed the technique and next
thing you know you're working on a disc
attack making a thousand dollars a night
whatever the [ __ ] they call them the
club
yeah you know it's true yeah it's like
anything else so you stick it out you
[ __ ] eat [ __ ] for a while and they
you know what when i was young i was
guilty of that [ __ ] too i did it a
thousand times
but when i bit my teeth into something
like comedy i i stuck with it
like i was just waiting to find the good
thing i liked i was waiting for
something to be better than drug dealing
how many jobs did you have like
i i can go on too like yeah yeah yeah
yeah painter yeah what about 18 and
where were you at 18.
at 18 what was i doing 18 i quit high
school going into my senior year
and i got a job loading trucks from
massback century hardware
right before senior year i quit like a
[ __ ] jerk off then i tried to go back
but it didn't work out for me
but that was my and but i remember the
see when i went home the other day i
thought of all the [ __ ] jobs i had
and there was a guy there was a couple
guys i used to go to a dog i need a job
i need a job with tormentum
they couldn't get out of the car without
me going dog what happened to that job
until they get me a job and then i go oh
[ __ ] they got me a job
i remember one year i got a job from uh
from carmine balzano he goes they want
to hire the carlo construction
the job was walking on a 2x12
with a wheelbarrow full of cement
for 10 hours a day
i would just count the days till the
paycheck like i would just work enough
to cover my nut for that weekend and a
couple days after that like what do i
need any 400
once i made 400 i just quit like this
ain't for me no more what happened i
[ __ ] quit and then i got it then my
buddy got me a job
putting shirts in the box and sending
orders shipping
okay bro i walked in there at eight
and by 8 30 i said let me go outside i
gotta breathe
pain yeah another time my friend got me
a job at a paint store on bergen white
avenue on a monday morning went in there
they had me carrying paint for the first
three hours eight bucks an hour
i was like you [ __ ] credit me and
right down the corner there was a coke
dealer who would front me i had a gold
watch that was fake i said [ __ ] it by 11
30 i put the whole deal together in my
head
i'd go down that time i'd be back in two
hours at the [ __ ] money give me a
half ounce of coke and i bring the watch
to him that was the end of that job
that was no more my friend called me
what happened dog they said you just
left dog i don't want to be breathing
those fumes
you know what i'm saying i got some
cocaine and snort you want me down there
breathing [ __ ] fumes then i got
another job that summer like 10 blocks
down
at a hardware store
and that lasted till i figured out how
to rob the register once they gave me a
[ __ ] angle to the register you
couldn't trust me around the register in
those days at all yeah when i was
younger i don't want sticky fingers like
a [ __ ] you would steal from the
register oh like it was my own
yeah that's what pete bowzano at gotham
he came and we were talking about one
time he got me a job at randall lumber
and he goes i got a job for you
it's five bucks an hour it's a great job
but do me a favor you gotta steal
because if you don't steal they're gonna
know how to steal
oh yeah you gotta cut the same record
and i had to keep the same record so
every sheet applied was 80 bucks
i was selling for 25 30. yeah it's black
market people come in and go let me get
10 sheets of plan well there's gonna
cost you 800.
what if
you gave me three papers and they go
loaded up [ __ ]
300 straight i figured they had the old
school register
so you buy a drill for 249
i'm bringing up 49. yeah it doesn't say
drill like the no it was the old school
right this is way before paperwork and
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] it up for people to
steal because all technology was
all technology is it's [ __ ] up for
people like me when i was young like
today's world i wouldn't survive because
you can't take a [ __ ] dime that way
not a dime we got cameras on top of
cameras inside the cameras there's
nothing you could do i worked at a movie
theater that fired someone for stealing
one bag of m m's yeah no no no in
incorporating corporate world now let's
pretend me and you and george take a bag
of peanut m peanuts and we take a break
somebody's getting fired tomorrow all
three of you would be somebody's getting
fired tomorrow it's [ __ ] crazy i
would never survive
a minute
a minute in today's corporate structure
a minute i did what i did at the right
[ __ ] time in my life
and without knowing i had no idea it was
going to become like this right you got
a job now you're going to sign that you
got to sign 80 documents
they do a background check right away
they [ __ ] it's it's it's a nightmare
but
something did happen to me the other day
dawg
what was the last time somebody rocked
your world judge
i rocked my world like a friend of yours
that just
this kid's always rocking my world
whenever i go home he's always
like just
done something i was telling lee lee
is here because he reminds me of this
kid lubes i grew up with
and when i got and loses a fiend he's
got no teeth left damn but the fact is
he put himself through mit dog as an
engineer the dude's a bad [ __ ]
he just never came out of the 80s
he just never you know i was stuck in
that [ __ ] too for a long time you know
once you get off the pattern you're
really off it
so every time i call him he always comes
to the hotel first and brings me big
ziti his mother made
a soda silverware a flower
the chocolate cake or whatever his
mother made it's always
so it's it's a bro all i have to do is
my plane lands all i gotta do is call
and go i'm ready for you
and then we he brings it we eat it we
take a ride we smoke a number we
reminisce and an hour later he goes home
and i won't see him again until i
[ __ ] leave oh wow that's all i need
from him this time i called him no show
oh
thursday no answer no show
right away i think he went over to the
feds
by the way you know my disgusting mind
and i said you know what maybe we've
been friends for too long maybe it's
time to move on yeah friday he calls me
up dog what are you doing you know i'm
gonna pick you up i gotta show a [ __ ]
seven o'clock i gotta leave for the city
he goes all right i'll call you tomorrow
morning first thing i get back from the
[ __ ] show last you know when you get
back from two shows dawg you're wired
for sound you're thinking about
everything you said
there's usually that show on tv about
the prisoners
and you watch that [ __ ] into the wee
hours and you're like that's [ __ ]
you know whatever
and even if even in prison today i would
fail
it's two corporate kites and [ __ ] no
cigarettes yeah it's too corporate i
would fail in prison today it's too much
[ __ ] paperwork
too much paperwork to [ __ ] survive
so anyway saturday morning i wake up
dawg i ate like eight [ __ ] stars i
ain't like sixteen hundred milligrams i
slept like a baby i hadn't slept in two
nights three nights the first night i
had to get up at four in the middle of
the night like a burglar the second
night i had to get up back opie and
anthony so at five remember at eight in
the morning i'm getting on the radio
it's really five in the morning
yeah so i got a time change i got up at
like three in the morning that day
and then friday i couldn't sleep i got
up at seven like [ __ ] i was going to
war
what the [ __ ] am i going i got nowhere
to go oh i love this [ __ ] that's why i
had to bring the city
so i knew friday night i was gonna go
down like this is all in new york it's
all in new york
saturday morning i wake up
and i got 19 missed calls
but as i look at the phone it rings
and it's loops and he goes where are you
going i've been calling you since i'm
looking at nine o'clock i go listen dawg
i'm just getting up
i just need a cup of coffee [ __ ] that
i'm around the corner let's get keeping
coffee no way he's in new york he's in
jersey i stayed in edgewater he jumps in
the [ __ ]
i jump in the shower i watch my little
monkey i come downstairs half dead
there's coffee there from starbucks i
ask the lady for a cup i give it a three
bucks
i don it i come out of my [ __ ] home i
had two joints in my wallet from the
night before
me and him went on a [ __ ] joyride of
death okay first of all this traffic
bumper-to-bumper
new york listen new york dog traffic is
brutal how's the weather is it cool the
weather was just this is listen if
you're gonna go to new york any time of
the year it's april
may or september
that's it don't go in july don't go in
august that humidity is a nightmare
june's a nightmare
february you gotta walk around with a
body suit from the cold weather
unless when you you know when you when
you go
yeah it's 10 below when you're here
people call you it's 74 degrees yeah
you know yeah i know so just avoid the
[ __ ] thing because you never know
what's going to win the skies in the
fall back there so he picks me up bro
this traffic bumper the bumper
george perez this [ __ ] is doing
90
around people in a left lane you know
like you faked the left turn cutting
people off he's got a badge in the car
oh wow he's old
old
school
licensed just got it back down i don't
worry about nothing in fact if they pull
me over i'll tell them i know anthony i
i went for anthony because my friend is
an assemblyman a freeholder oh and he
runs north bergen so he goes i i just
tell him i did it like three times
people they just let me go
so we're cutting people off cutting
people i gotta go to union city to go to
the jewelry store i gotta get to my uh
buy flowers from my mother's grave
because that was the most important
whenever i get back there i gotta go
right to the cemetery but thursday i had
to go to opie and anthony when i got
back i called bobby he wasn't there he
couldn't drive me so i got caught up so
saturday we're going down to the
cemetery to get flowers that's this
cuban place
that's been there for like 20 30 years
it's called dos amigos all they do is
cuban steak sandwiches cuban milkshakes
and cuban sodas that's it but the cuban
steak sandwich bro they get the french
fries
they cook them and then they take them
out of the deep fry and they throw them
in with the steak and mix them with the
steak and the onions they throw
seasoning on and this potatoes are soft
then they put on that cuban bread and
they cut it in half and your world
changes when you bite it but the problem
is every time you go down you get 15
tickets
you can't park the line is huge and
[ __ ] you got a double park some
people just go [ __ ] it i'll get 10
sandwiches and get the 60 dollar ticket
it's worth the aggravation that's the
mentality that's how good the [ __ ]
sandwiches are like the yankees get up
get tickets all the time
the football players yeah they don't
give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] they
double parked the suv's going there let
me get six to go and [ __ ] 22 with cheese
eight without cheese like a [ __ ]
they got that cube and soda they got
sugar cane juice that's why i brought
them together uh
i didn't even touch it what's cuban soda
mateba mate you don't iron beer
and then they have a malta toy manta
atway that's that's my favorite they got
a couple maltese but i'm on that way
dude
but mateba is the [ __ ] now they have a
diet mattel and a diet [ __ ] iron beer
you understand me fat [ __ ] like me
can't lose
and i don't think i've gotten more texts
from you than i did this weekend and
every day it was just the delicious
delicious food and and they got like
more and more delicious and you just
started laughing when i would call you
because you knew how like like i wanted
to jump on the plane because i'm trying
to i'm trying to [ __ ] take lee
lee eats [ __ ] today we passed by this
skinny kitchen
for six months i like the skinny kitchen
it's delicious they have great buffalo
burgers what the shut down the other
place gave him [ __ ] agility he got
lizard meat
yeah he got his dad sick i mean it's
just he's a geico dick yeah he eats
terrible food he just has terrible
because he goes on yelp and he believes
with a bunch of gentiles
i never ate food in l.a well there's a
great hot dog then you go there and it
tastes like dick the bread is cold
i have bad luck i guess but it's just
and you were saying you said you were so
happy at that uh sandwich place that you
sent me the picture of the bill because
it was 22 dollars two cuban steak
sandwiches a milkshake and two [ __ ]
sodas okay 21 delicious though and the
steak sandwich was like this dog with
raw onions cooked onions and the french
fries on top of it like these guys fat
cells they just put mcdonald's fries on
your [ __ ] sandwich and gravy that
ain't no [ __ ] there's no creativity
in those mcdonald's fries the cubans cut
the potatoes
so they bend and they leave the [ __ ]
skin on [ __ ]
we ain't got time to [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
yeah you know
yeah i'm i'm [ __ ] you and then they
had like three different types of hot
sauce i put the franks on that
[ __ ] with that that diet imb i
was good to go but listen we pull up in
front of the place there's no parking
but there's a handicapped pocket
not only we just do 90 and we cut off
half a jersey
he got what would it would have taken
you and i a half hour what he did in
seven minutes no way and he got me there
and also he parks in the handicap and he
whips out a handicap sticking he goes
this is why i paid 15 every two years
he popped that [ __ ] in there we
both went over into that [ __ ] place
we ordered our sandwich we got back in
the car we made [ __ ] another u-turn
cut 19 people off drove on the sidewalk
and next you know on 48th street making
a left onto bergen line [ __ ] avenue
but traffic is bumping the bumper we go
[ __ ] it mom's flowers are better again
cuts people off kennedy boulevard 30
left turns right turns blinkers i mean
it was [ __ ] tremendous the whole time
stuttering
music is on you know telling me stories
and [ __ ] i'm howling i'm hollering
because nobody would believe this pops
are left a u-turn we get flowers from my
mother boom we go down the [ __ ] hill
uh we shoot in we go into the cemetery
there's people there with their families
their grandkids are running around look
at grandma dead grandma he don't give a
[ __ ] he's because they have double
parked too
he's driving on the bodies and [ __ ]
he knocked over a tombstone
we cut half through the [ __ ] thing we
get to my spot i clean off my mother's
grave i say 10 prayers he's 10 feet from
me
i rip up the [ __ ] grass i lay the
flowers down this my i smell reefer i go
what do i smelt reef i turn around it's
him with a joint he's like hey your mom
smoked
did he stutter too dawg he started i
looked at him for like two minutes like
this [ __ ] and i go this is why i
love this kid i go give me that [ __ ]
joint
i blew it on the [ __ ] tombstone
i said finish it he gave me a little
roach and i left it right there on the
tombstone until the next time i see your
mama [ __ ] smoker with you i'll bring
you some better [ __ ]
we got back in the [ __ ] car and then
he did 90 on totally cutting people off
and then in the meanwhile there she says
to me hey i i got something for you
he goes under his seat and he gives me a
baggie with like four pills in it oh i
got one of these because you said your
back was hurting take those i go what
are they going i don't know
i don't know at least he's honest at
least he's honest then we took another
one
he ran this house and he brought down a
pint of cannoli flavor that timeline see
have been saving for me since wednesday
what is it
cannoli flavor the italian ice that he'd
been saving for me for this
[ __ ]
i took the [ __ ] canola i looked at
him i took two spoons out of it licked
it and gave it back no no no no
it's for you i go i end up looking like
you you [ __ ]
dog i laughed the whole [ __ ] two
hours
he didn't shut the [ __ ] up
stuttering like it was 1982
smoking throwing cigarettes out the
window i mean everything he did was
illegal bro
nobody but nobody lives like that no
more even for a minute there he jolted
me but i go you know what
every night i sit in my [ __ ] house
george perez
going what the [ __ ] is my doing with my
life i sit here i play with a three and
a half year old
i watch tv i talk to my wife she goes to
bed i sit here and watch narcos and
salivate
because i'm just hitting people in the
head with sticks and snorting blows i'm
telling people to suck my dick and call
them money guys and [ __ ]
her times change and all of a sudden i
get in the car with this lunatic and
it's the [ __ ] best 20 minutes i've
had the last 10 years bro
[ __ ] yeah man it's old school friends
and the car is worth 500
hear the brakes screeching he told me i
i i paid 500 for this three years ago i
only changed the oil
you you've always said that if you if
your mom was alive you would have like
probably lived at home like lubes yeah
could you imagine if you and lubes were
still together in north bergen just
living in your mom's first person
oh [ __ ] how old are you
sixteen
fifteen
fifteen damn he looked at me like a
soldier was [ __ ] laying down
and then we started snorting thc crystal
oh that [ __ ] that makes you [ __ ] see
death stars and stuff
it was a good trip i see
timmy i saw mike batula [ __ ] i saw
mcmahon's i saw a bunch of [ __ ]
people i hadn't seen carlos neri
thursday i didn't work i just went to
barron's bar
is that in jersey too yeah real close to
where i was staying a bunch of my
friends came from the seventh grade
sixth grade dog and we just sat there
till 10 o'clock
we drank a beer we hugged them we went
home that was it i didn't want to
[ __ ] i just wanted to see these
people
and uh tell them that you know
when i was in prison like i told them
and i had to tell you when i was in
prison
i think about you people i thought about
you people and i was ashamed of but
when i was in the settle the longest
yard i also thought about you people and
thought about how proud i was trying to
make you by doing this you know
straight up because i knew those people
when i was straight dog and the girl
said to me she goes what have you ever
sent lovito a check
levita was my sixth grade teacher who
had a wig
and on fridays you had two options bro
you go to ccd religious instruction
where you could sit through the ecology
club for two hours and learn how to
throw papers and [ __ ] in the garbage
i didn't want to do either so i got
thrown out of the ccds so i had to go
back to levito but the leader goes you
know what a bunch of people don't want
to [ __ ] sit and learn on uh talk
about educa environment on friday there
were about 20 of us and he would go once
you go to the front of the class and
sing
and every friday we would have a talent
show oh and i would sing my eyes adored
you by frankie valley and i would walk
around with a brand new shirt on like i
was [ __ ] vinnie bananas and [ __ ]
and you did it for the whole year i
played for about eight months then i i
switched up to the jackson five
oh it's whatever no no but i could
remember i could sing i would sing the
beatles help
oh [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] but it was him who
got me i was bro when you're in the
sixth grade you're going up in front of
a bunch of animals
[ __ ] the comedy story and [ __ ] 20 years
later you
those people were animals in the sixth
grade
they would throw a desk at you those
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] what's going on with you george
perez i know you always got [ __ ]
cracking man uh just uh i got the
you know i just finished writing a
little short film that i finally getting
together like
it's cool we'll see where that takes me
uh i did that i did the joe rogan
podcast man and like it's weird like
i've never ever had that many email
alerts
and like i'm just cool right now man a
lot of good stuff's going on chilling i
oh i saw a red band putting you on those
wednesday shows
yeah the secret shows and i would see
that joe was on the shows and i
i wanted to know how long it would take
you and joe to finally connect in a
certain way you know
joe and ari are the type of people that
they don't care about your past there's
people that tell you they don't care
about your past but they really do they
use it against you dumb situation i know
exactly what you mean ari well has been
one guy that's always been a supporter
of my past and he's always
regardless of what's happened you know
joe
will take a while
he's a little bit more keen and careful
and he'll look at you from a different
perspective and then eventually he'll
see you for what you are and then you're
in you'll see the situation that you're
in and what you're doing to make it
better
you know it's not that we're judgmental
but you know how comedy it is the way it
is they said
these people come up to you and then
listen i want to do this and this and
this and you try to do something they
blow up a spot no now you look like you
have anything on your [ __ ] face guess
what i did it to joe too
i did it to joe so
joe just understands me
he knows you're [ __ ] nuts i get it
you know you're nuts i get it where no
nobody else understands that one day we
were talking to joe was like you'd be on
my tv show if i had it
just off the cuff in the back of the
comedy store he goes what's up he goes
i'll tell you what i would do i would
shoot you first and get you the [ __ ] out
of it before anybody even noticed
i went home like what a brilliant
[ __ ] idea
that's how you get people to troublesome
and [ __ ] off your set why would you have
me there till seven if you know i'm
gonna break your balls just get the [ __ ]
out of here
you know it's like tracy morgan you
think tracy morgan they shot tracy
morgan and got him out of there i
guarantee you
next time i see him i'll ask him i
guarantee he would go in by eight
yeah and leave by 12 and all the women
would come at 12 just because he says
crazy [ __ ]
you know what you're gonna get crazy
[ __ ] out of him that's the artist that
he is the [ __ ] comic that he is he's
dangerous
you want a funny guy some of them got to
be dangerous
but then what happens
when you have actors who get in trouble
like a lindsay lohan or whatever when
you because that means you're kind of
enabling them in a way right like people
have gotten in trouble like with the
charlie sheens and lindsay lohan's like
to a to a degree that gets dangerous i
think
listen i'm not talking about drug use
here okay i'm talking about comedy
dangerous
people who are buck wild on the set the
worst thing i'll do on a set out of
respect for anybody on that set is smoke
pot
i would never go to a cell with alcohol
on my breath and i would never snore
coke and go to a set even when i was
doing blow i would never go on a set
like that and there are people who do
who do that i could imagine they are i
don't know i've never seen them i've
never heard of it but
why not sometimes i drink a little on
the set
no i'm not on the sound like on like a
tv set yeah no when you're doing a movie
there's people oh [ __ ] i'll never do
nothing like that listen nbc signs the
show you're on the show as a comic they
do 100 episodes right
somewhere along the line you got to
moderate your behavior to that show yeah
and it sucks and and the the [ __ ]
anti
whatever in you
says [ __ ] all this [ __ ] but you got two
options you do two years you make a
little bank and you get off
and you do it like a gentleman did i
know that when i was 35 33 when i first
moved here [ __ ] no
i see it now and i'm telling you if you
don't want to be on the show just say
after two years i don't want to be on
this show
but don't [ __ ] blow it up and then
nobody else is gonna hide
yeah your reps on the line and then
nobody else is gonna hire you or it's
gonna take a year or two
for somebody to go give him a chance
he's grown up since then which usually
does
listen that [ __ ] dude iron man you
you know this was a dude that was going
off
he went off for got to be 15 years
what's his name de niro no no robert
downey jr
jr
i'm high as [ __ ] right now robert downey
jr that dude slipped
had to be 15 years
had to be 15 years
brilliant the guy is [ __ ] watch less
than zero watch
a couple [ __ ] movies i can't remember
right now because i'm high as [ __ ] but
less than zero is one of those movies
man where he brought his addiction to
the stage
it's like night do you ever see him he
sucks dick no no way bro he sounds dick
in that movie damn the dude comes and
picks him up and takes and drops him off
to suck dick
he's foaming from the mouth
oh yeah he's goes deep in that [ __ ]
movie robs his family goes into his
family's house the family throws him out
his [ __ ] thing is foaming i'm sitting
there going who the [ __ ] does that
remind you
this guy hit it on the goddamn if you
did blow and you fiended and you [ __ ]
people over when you watched that movie
your heart stopped she's like this
[ __ ] just gave my autobiography
he didn't do that good of a job was it
the writing or was it his performance
watch
yeah they'll have a scene in there where
they come get them or something
i did opiate anthony and james spade was
on the show
oh okay and he was the coat dealer in
that
you know you can't even imagine him as a
coke dealer
i mean it was like a 19 california drug
dealer you know what i'm saying like it
wasn't a he wasn't like a dog i got in
the [ __ ] cab the other day
with some cab driver from like bolivia
oh yeah he was on the east coast and
this [ __ ] went off about two
nationalities
dominicans and cholos he goes i love
mexican people but [ __ ] cholos
they're no good they're no good
lost
all right less than zero late
we got a bad rap right right there that
second one right there look at him he
was a baby
oh yeah this has to be 87 88
because it was
it has to be
i can't 90 maybe what you use he's a
dope fiend in this [ __ ] yeah uh like the
white oh no like the white version of
chris rock in new jack city
no just as bad damn
gatherly what's going on here
kick that [ __ ] mule [ __ ]
let's see if they show the coke scenes
oh this is a video for the [ __ ] the
song oh that's not it sorry
you know what's cool is he donated like
a mill excuse me a million dollars
in tv
the movie rumors right there the fourth
video on the way down okay
he donated one i'm sorry no it's go he
donated plasmas to the la county jail
because he stayed there for a little bit
he put two million bucks they had
plasmas in all the day rooms see yeah
yeah you know
oh there's another [ __ ] video oh they
keep messing with you
look at james spader with the red shirt
on playing coke dealer
do you want to see
yeah they got no videos for it don't
worry about loving
some of these motherless [ __ ]
yeah he's such like an orange county
looking drug dealer like he yeah this is
well this is beverly hills yeah like
this is beverly hills and whatnot but it
was an interesting movie
and that guy went through hell all those
years and then when they found them in
palm springs with the catwoman suit or
won the woman's suit in the closet and
[ __ ]
you know that means the hooker was
coming over and he was dressing her up
87 87 who do you think you're dealing
with joey bananas that movie came out i
went to prison
oh [ __ ] i remember that when i saw that
movie i was waiting to get sentenced
and i'm watching him and i'm going
that's what i was doing last night
foaming from the mouth just like that
walking around my room crawling looking
under the [ __ ] door
like an [ __ ] jerking off the debt for
what
for what
yeah man uh the craziest [ __ ] i've done
is like go outside and like
make my neighbor's motion lights go on
you ever just walk by the house to see
if their lights work
that's the craziest [ __ ] i've done when
you're cooked up
that's crazy for me dog i wouldn't leave
the house oh yeah i have to because like
i feel like entrapped like when i'm
outside it's free there's air this i
could smoke
so that's back in the day though no i
couldn't do that [ __ ] and go outside you
know man it's uh
the last couple weeks i've been getting
emails
i got like two a week and they want it
in depth
like i know people like and when
people's emails and i have to write them
back listen man at this time we don't
have that kind of time or paperwork
i could scroll for two hours you know
and it bothered me when i gave people
that reply when people go can you please
tell me how you got your life together
after prison or can you please help me
i'm trying to get my life together i
don't know how to [ __ ] to do it
can you please go and take your time and
detail it for me and i'll go you know i
just don't have it
because
fifty percent of this i don't know how i
did it
you know what i'm saying like i don't
know how i get it yeah
you know i did comedy until it beat up
the crime
i was still shoplifting and doing stupid
[ __ ] and then when i moved to l.a i
wasn't doing no crimes but i was doing
dumb [ __ ]
like taking lighters from curse on that
7-eleven in there and just trying to get
by you know your 7-eleven down the
street put the lighters under the
counter now did they which one the one
on magnolia
i clipped them for a lighter a month out
of respect when they break my balls
when the guys put the pizza in and i
gotta wait there for five minutes my
light is going down
i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] and it's so weird
how you do it because they actually see
it in your hand
and when they ring it up you put it in
your pocket take the cash out and they
don't know if you're a magician they
don't want to accuse you they know
you're a regular and they just shake
their head like this [ __ ] got me
for a lighter you ain't gonna [ __ ]
[ __ ] isis with my niggles you know
what i'm saying i saw at the scary one
on chandler the guy hit on a girl and
she wasn't having any she he got pissed
when she left oh sure that's isis bro
that's the craziest one ever
when they when they hit on the girls no
on chandler and laura it's called isis
no it's called several [ __ ] i was like
but it's isis
it's called
it's like their little underground
[ __ ] it's one that they gave it to
them you said you
clicked like the owner and the two
owners in the back blood out
they haven't carried them to the 170 yet
they're still in the back tied up
bleeding and they're just going there we
don't even know what they're doing what
do you want sick of that yeah
where's my mother went back to india
he'll call you
it's been 14 months he had problems
the visa him his wife
they were nice people yes they were it's
[ __ ] crazy and they're playing like
the music wasn't on but he was just
hitting on her hard but there's a young
guy that's kind of good looking the one
with the hair i don't know does he have
the turban on
i think he does but i think sometimes he
just has a ponytail yeah there's one guy
that's kind of nice in the daytime but
the chick that works there's mexican
with a lot of teeth she's isis
all right oh yeah she's mexican [ __ ]
evil [ __ ] she's just not nice
for a spanish chick not to be nice or
smile she's they already brainwashed she
got she got good paperwork what does she
do what did they do what do they call it
radicalization yeah they already
barely eradicated i didn't know those
mechanizes no they wrestled well if you
look at what's going on right now on the
east coast isis is shaving their beards
but the mexicans and the the spanish
people in hudson county are living that
b is long
why because everybody wants to be
[ __ ] the star
everybody wants to be [ __ ] hip and
have a [ __ ] beat now
and when they're your color
they can't tell the cops so when you get
shot don't come crying to me you had
that [ __ ] beer first off your spanish
you got this you're disrespecting half
of them with with castro with [ __ ] you
want to grow a [ __ ] beer like alibaba
i get emotional i'm sorry about [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying sometimes
beards bother me because i don't know
the purpose of them
you know like when ari had a beard he
was my goomba but i couldn't really run
with him with a [ __ ] beard why you
got a beard for it yeah i can't [ __ ]
with that
if you're a hasidic jew all right grow
the beard let it go [ __ ] it i'm with you
but you're a [ __ ] mexican dude with a
[ __ ] beard what mexican has a [ __ ]
beard
when who
yeah when show me [ __ ] viva zapata
who had a [ __ ] beard anthony quinn
what are they allowed to have mustaches
mustache mustache deep [ __ ] mustaches
with two guns under their ponchos that's
called the brochure
the [ __ ] we
but it's just really weird but what do
you think the main ingredient was
and you staying on the straight and
narrow and you know
wow well you know what first getting out
was like adjusting and and knowing that
there was a consequence if i went back
like hey
when you get out it's a 90-day violation
to go back like no matter what any
parole violation so
i already had something like bordering
me and then
at the same time you know i had a
daughter man i had sons and
i was like i'm done bullshitting
hey and it's just like how you said you
know here and there i i [ __ ] around
like it's hard because we have bad
habits bad habits of stuff we know we
can get away with like i'm not gonna get
caught for this i'm gonna get away with
it that was the hardest habit that i had
to like
you know what i'm not gonna fight no
more man just
like to say no to walk away those are
the hardest weird habits cause i've
always got away with it how often were
you getting in fights
dude when i got out of prison people
were like just
messing with me but they weren't i
thought they were because i still had
that like hey dog don't step on my shoe
like don't worry don't look at me like
that like it was weird okay i i had a
[ __ ] up thing happen yesterday to me
we were we went to the dodgers game and
we were sitting paul got these seats and
there was these like three guys next to
them and they were they were mexican and
they were they
and i left once to go get drinks
and
i came back and he she said he said
something not like two not two but just
like hey why are you smiling like trying
to like maybe hit on her a little bit
and in my head i was like i should say
something
but then again i'm i'm by myself with he
has three friends i don't really want to
get stabbed
but i felt like an [ __ ]
and then i was like oh then well this is
why you do do two but even what you did
so i couldn't that wouldn't be good for
me
not at a dodger game so now you're not
at that so that's the thing so like but
i was like i felt like i feel [ __ ] up
about it i feel like i should have just
been like hey man like at least said
something but
i don't know it's just it's
i i understand that went to those
tickets uh she got them a groupon i mean
do they even have groupon tickets yeah
they have i mean they have um for the
last game the vin schooling one well she
got the months ago for her mom but then
her mom's in mexico for two weeks i mean
i'd love to know what it costs for me to
go to a game and not get [ __ ]
harassed
well i'd love to know what it cost for
me to take my wife and daughter and not
feel like a [ __ ] victim in there
right you had to get like booth and i
said to you before you went i go
you know anytime somebody tells me
they're going to an event like that now
a [ __ ] dodger game a ram game
you know the other place you don't get
beat up is that lego games yeah why not
i never understood that anime they've
already had beeps the first two or three
weeks security
people raider fans are writing fight
raider fans yeah well laker games is
like warriors like everyone just meets
up all the gangs they all wear the same
[ __ ] and everyone that's lakers is
lakers nobody's ever been shot in the
world
i've never no you because it's a
basketball game it's got to be the gangs
i don't know what gangs are out there
i'm not [ __ ] gang land the only one i
remember is
gotta be at least 10 years ago the
indiana one where they went into the
state and where they look oh yeah that
was when uh ron artest went in the
stands and started beating people up
that's the only thing i can remember
what we're talking
shooting each other in the nba game
i think that was a kid what's his name
took a gun out of an nba game but that
was completely different marvin bad news
bonds
had a neck game when he got ejected and
[ __ ] but that [ __ ]
you know he got stopped in 10 airports
in his career for carrying 10 guns and
she didn't give a [ __ ]
a mom and bad news bonds and [ __ ]
jesus christ that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah i mean even in high school football
games and all that but yeah never nba
game
that's weird i mean you know i would my
my agent said to me i have boxed it or
whatever
season ticket so does bert greisha so
does burke cry you know
i sit and i go why would you know if
there's nine home games you're gonna get
clocked in the head one time the odds
are against you
nine times you gotta go down there park
and walk in there
one of those nine times you're either
gonna get with a pretzel or punch to the
[ __ ] head what if you you know
i mean now they're beating you up even
if you're the home team
they're coming to your stadium and
beating you up that's who gets beat up
now the home team
the home team gets beat up they're
coming out with their little jerseys on
there you go
you want to win not no more you're going
to win the [ __ ] hospital oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] crazy so you know what that zaps
me the [ __ ] out of that but do you think
green bay's like that i don't think
green bay is like that
like well not yet la's like it's too
cold to act like stupid in green bay you
get smacked in your face in the
wintertime that stays with you for a
[ __ ] lifetime you ever get smacked in
the wind outside no no you i did
it's not pretty get hit with a
basketball in the nose
in the wintertime after you've been
outside for an hour dad's [ __ ] with
gloves on with the fingertips cut off so
you can handle the ball
and the ball don't bounce because it's
frozen how about that one for you you
just got to pass the ball and you go to
shoot the ball and somebody follows you
you have no idea
in the wintertime what it's like to hear
this on a frozen face when you hear this
on a frozen face what about just playing
football and just catching the ball when
it's freezing out listen it's a
nightmare even with the [ __ ] patch
even as a kid when it's like when you're
just playing two-hand touch
so when i was a kid i went through car
windows i'm still thinking all right
when you were kidding car windows listen
they used to play street hockey on
giving that terrace
and one day i thought i was cool when i
put the [ __ ] you had to go to tom
mccann and get nhl sneakers they look
different they they do the thing
i went up there and those days sneakers
cost what 12 bucks most [ __ ] sneakers
cost 22 23 i bought those things like
dean lapreet these crazy white dudes
talked me into playing street hockey and
next thing i went down there i didn't
know what was going on next thing you
know bro the game ended
when a [ __ ] car glass
broke your [ __ ] head
because they would tackle you against
the car
and one day we played some lunatics from
some other street and some kid's head
got busted some kid's leg he slid
and it got caught in the under the car
wasn't moving
the car was parked
but he got caught on like ice and his
leg went under it and he held up
so he broke his own [ __ ] leg because
he had his arm
as he went in and you heard the leg
and all of a sudden yelling when you're
[ __ ] 12 and 10 you can't go and then
one time they checked me is that what
that's called yeah when they check you
yeah and my head went in i didn't but
the glass went were you wearing a helmet
oh yeah you should have seen me with my
[ __ ] helmet
if you showed up in those days with a
helmet leave they'd let you put on and
then they [ __ ] take it off and beat
you with it and take you to the [ __ ]
alley i played three i played street
hockey three times
and that was it did you even have a
stick he was around no i bought the
whole thing you know me in those days i
was robbing my stepfather's lawyer phone
i'll take 220s and go right to jungle
square and get a [ __ ] hockey stick
the gloves i had everything i was ready
to play why not just buy the helmet then
because in those days you didn't wear
helmets lee it's street hockey
that's why whatever you have a [ __ ]
fruit cake yeah
you're 10. i didn't know
i'm 10 10 year olds are crazy i'm just
someone hit someone in the head
i want you to give me the psychology i'm
11 right i just got thrown out of
catholic school i needed friends for
beating up the nun i was spanish
nobody spanish wanted to hang out with
me because i was crazy we did numbers
my family the numbers did the santeria
so the spanish people stayed away from
me so i finally found a little group of
white kids that would let me hang out
with them and [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
and that's how it falls that's it that's
how it works out i told you i went down
there three times and that was it for me
they were [ __ ] street animals
they were street animals i couldn't do
that did you play any other sports with
them
like did you guys play football we
played football and all that stuff
listen i played like uh
i never i never played nothing in north
bergen because by the time i even got
integrated in north berlin it was too
late i was 12 or 13. i had been away at
school at catholic school
i got thrown out in the sixth grade
so i got thrown on the fifth i didn't
hit north bergen until the sixth grade
even though i had lived there since 73
i went to school somewhere else and
everything i did was in the city like uh
uh we used to play football with
shoulder pads but no pants it was semi
i'm saying
your [ __ ] kids
that's what i did no i liked all that
stuff i was basically a basketball guy
that didn't know what he was doing
and i would go to other towns because in
those days in the 70s it was loose
if i had a cousin that lived in glendale
i used his address and played glendale
wreck
if lee syed lived in [ __ ] north
hollywood
i used lee science
so i would have t-shirts from all those
towns
i would go to all those leagues my
mother had a ball in unicity my dad had
a business in west new york uh you
follow me we had a house in north bergen
he was local my friend had a [ __ ]
garage in guttenberg
we knew everybody so when we played i
played in all those leagues until they
found that and threw me out
playing the field how was it that's the
way to get better at basketball i would
go to all those little [ __ ] things
saint anthony's cyo i would go all the
way down there and take the bus or take
my bicycle you play on multiple teams in
a year like multiple games at once yeah
it's basketball season so one league
will be on tuesday nights the other
league would be on wednesday nights the
league will be on thursday nights and
there'll be a league on friday night
what would you say when they say hey
where do you who do you have for science
but i don't know i go to i go to st
jones or something i would make
something up
you needed was address it was an address
where do you go to school as long as you
live in that township you go to school
in jersey city you don't give a [ __ ]
you're playing the wreck here oh right
so the practices start at 6 30 i would
play wherever my school was till 5 30.
practice gets up right school stuff yeah
school ends at three practice sets at 3
30 to five
i would eat something take a bus to the
other [ __ ] rec center boom play
next night boom and i remember when i i
went you know what three seconds is yeah
a three second violation is when you
stand oh yes
one of my most [ __ ] moments in my
life was i had the shirt i had the
basket i had the limousines for the feet
and [ __ ] that matched my shirt and [ __ ]
never mind you had limousines for the
feet but if you have limousines for the
feet that match your shirt forget about
it
forget about it and then you have the
shorts i had the knee pads like julia
serving
i didn't want to play basketball but i
really didn't know the rules
i had
played played
i had played street basketball and the
street basketball you don't have the
ball you could sit under the net yeah so
i'll never forget them picking me like
this guy's badass like some dudes like
we saw them doggy jams
because again it's not how many people
you shoot until you shoot
i would get ready i would do all that
[ __ ] just to get ready for saturday down
at gilmore school because there was a
kid at gilmore school his name was
dracula
and he was six foot two and he slammed
dunked and all the right and all the rep
all that if you really were good at
basketball you went down on saturdays
never mind if you got picked you didn't
see the ball you just played defense but
just to be on drak's team and talk [ __ ]
by your homie [ __ ] what'd you do i was
hanging with drac
[ __ ]
we beat these [ __ ] 16 too he
slammed dunk i fed him an alley-oop i
blocked this shot you didn't do dick i
didn't do dick i just ran back and forth
hey i'm open nobody even gave me the
[ __ ] ball you kid
did you ever get picked
i got picked because i had a hustle and
i would die but nobody gave me the
[ __ ] boy man good game come on we're
back up again this time i'll give you
the ball and you're saying to them dog i
was opening the wing i got a deadly 12.
you know what i'm saying how old were
they like 18 probably dad it'd be 15 16
and i'm just a [ __ ] mope 12 year old
but having fun and they would say listen
dawg we're gonna give you the ball on
the side you'd be waiting out there like
a [ __ ]
like a kid on sunday waiting for your
stepdad to come and pick you up you'd be
out there
it was [ __ ] brutal guys
it's like comedy man
it's like comedy first three years of
comment nobody picks you for dick
no one picks you for dick and your
buddies get picked all around you you're
sitting there like a [ __ ] face [ __ ]
no i look at what you're doing i see the
rap battles i see the comedy central
thing
yeah man i'm just [ __ ] grinding hard
you know it's cool i stopped doing all
those little fundraisers and car wash
shows and all that not that they're bad
but i just said i'm gonna go to the
store and get better be around better
and be around the best and it's
it's nothing so far but it's something
you know i'm happy from what i'm getting
and i'm grateful and i'm just going to
keep pushing
you know
you know the toughest thing than
anything is just to get in
and then you prove yourself and then
people take to you little by little and
that's in any field
you know people want all this quick
recognition and [ __ ] you go there you
get there on time you do your job
and next you know people start looking
at you going you know what call lee lee
a [ __ ] do it
yeah and next you know he's got a call
he's got an extra [ __ ] gig and
somebody else easily and that's
basically
what this is when i got here i used to
look at people go away monday
my girlfriend didn't feel good and i go
we're doing comedy bro
just kind of do with your girlfriend
you're up there by yourself on the mic
you give your girlfriend michael
okay give her a shot of michael and you
[ __ ] disappear for two hours two
hours is all you need at night yeah
straight up especially if you have
friends they cover you george i really
need a spot tonight bro my wife's been
sick for three days can you hook me up
for seven minutes just to try this new
joke i read boom people
[ __ ] yeah and when i first got here my
mentality was i was out
every night
every night you know when i i once heard
that when you go to a.a they say you
have the first 90 days when you come out
of a rehab
are the most crucial first 120 days you
have to go to aaa meetings 120 days in a
row at least two meetings a day
i looked at that as comedy
i really did until it overcame
everything i was [ __ ] hungry too i
lived in a cartoon dog i took showers at
the start coke big deal
you gotta [ __ ] do something with your
life you have to give something to it
they're not just gonna open up the
[ __ ] factory for you unless you're
with three arts or apa or caa and at
that time those people wouldn't even
[ __ ] walk in the room where i was so
but i'm still [ __ ]
mesmerized by you
the
how long have you been out for now six
years six years six years number twenty
five see what i'm saying like keep tabs
on your [ __ ] stuff
so when we met you were just getting out
like a year yeah i was like
yeah
that's crazy it's
it's really funny like i was noticing
with you
and agastino and because i've been
around i've gotten to see like a lot of
like great shows with joey over the over
the years and it's it's it's actually
been really cool to see the same people
who have been on the shows like
get better
like it's it's like oh it's like because
you if i haven't seen you for a while
and then i get to see you and it it
i love
people people will come up to me like i
heard you laughing back there i love
going to the shows and giggling and
laughing so it's really cool because you
come look you're always at like at least
one show a year usually with joey so
it's cool to get to see you and like oh
thank you the difference between like
five and six years oh [ __ ] yeah you know
it's
it's like how joey said you just go five
times a week and you give it out and
one thing he told me all the time he's
right he's like right get the [ __ ] up
right doesn't matter when you do it do
it and
keep working on it and it gets better
i'm [ __ ] high as [ __ ] right now guys
yeah you know what
i sat with willy a couple of times to
help me with the special
you know you're doing comedy 25 years
you think you know all the [ __ ]
angles and that's that with that [ __ ]
genius cardiologist of a [ __ ] writer
because that's what he is a cardiologist
to [ __ ] writing
just little things and i've been
catching myself on stage doing them oh
because you close say that line and then
go into it
so make that that line go into it
so sometimes [ __ ] lee looks like a
terrorist
you know [ __ ] terrorist other you
know what i'm saying like yeah just it's
just a role little things that
you learn from people and you pick up
you know
but i tell you to answer your question
the one i asked you that was has been
killing me
you know i really think that sticking to
your guns
is the most important thing to turn your
life around
and when i say sticking to your guns
you're going to understand this george
when you stick to your guns
people who loved you
some of them you're going to shake away
because they don't understand where
you're coming from you know what i'm
saying yeah i kind of feel that you're
coming to your house you're coming i i'm
your old buddy
and i know you love me i got love for
you and i want you to be a comic but
guess what bro you were gone [ __ ] two
years now to smoke with [ __ ] lee that
[ __ ] never brings rolling papers
he comes over he's my mother's leftovers
and [ __ ]
i want to talk to you and [ __ ] you know
so now i want to come over tuesday night
and also you're like hold on one second
before you light that joint i gotta go
and people what about that party on
saturday can you make my party
i got three shows in prayer that night
yeah
you know and all of a sudden it's like
uh
i'm getting married can you do this can
you do this and all of a sudden your
availability list starts falling off so
people start looking you
differently i had a batch of friends
and it haunts me every day i love them
dearly we partake with each other we
game to one another
it was a commune
1440 gardener will always go down in my
heart i drive by there whenever i go to
hollywood night beep
even though everything is changed in the
building that building means more to me
than anything because that's the old one
you should live at right all of a sudden
no
oh okay i don't know
gardner is el compadre okay whenever you
hear all my el campage stories there was
that building there first person who was
it you ralphie the first person to ever
have an apartment there was
a kid that moved to alaska
and he gave the appointment to doug
stanhope
oh [ __ ] doug stanhope had his apartment
on curson and this apartment
on gardiner which is two blocks away
from each other and doug would go over
there at night and just have little
parties
and then when ralphie came to town in 99
and 98 98
doug said ralphie stay here
oh ralphie stayed there first
john wesley stayed with him jody
frederick lived on him and i looked at
him i lived in the corner by the floor
right on the floor the roaches were
crawling on me and the whole thing
but then as the people came out from
houston
jody got an apartment in the building
her sister gentry got an apartment in
the building oh and another friend from
houston celine lived in the building
then our other friend gavin moved in the
building
so that was only one two three
four
five six seven eight apartments
and five of them were us
oh
do you follow me
yeah you run that [ __ ] so celine now i
didn't have an apartment
you just were like like the woman i just
went to wherever there was a couch
or a bed so jody and gentry would travel
and they would leave me the keys to
their apartment
and i would sweep the apartment you know
i would take care of it i don't like
people over my place anyway at night you
know maybe something was stolen i
wouldn't and then when jody would come
back celine would be shooting
jamie kennedy's
show and they'd be out of town and i
would stay there on the couch for three
days damn then ralphie would [ __ ] be
out of town for two weeks
it was it just worked out
it was just such a and you went in some
refrigerators and some days they had
food and some days you went to the store
and bought food and people cooked it for
you
it was something that it was two years
of my life that that's why i let the bum
on fire
that's why i did so much evil you know
that el cambodia was right there i was
in the heyday of my cocaine addiction oh
if it wasn't for me my wife i would have
died in that [ __ ] building on the
roof because i would go to the roof late
at night and snort and bring people up
damn freaks and [ __ ]
that bikini looks nice on you
so that's where you were before you met
your wife yeah jeez
that's a 99 gavin boyd moved into the
building
i was
in 98
gavin boyd i was going on the road
for six weeks and on the second week of
the road i got a call from gavin going
when you come back you have a place to
sleep
full time you can sleep on my couch i
got a one bedroom
and i'm gonna need you here to look
after [ __ ] just little by little so
when i got back there
i stayed in gavin's but gavin had the
dog and they were pissing on me when i
was sleeping
and he would open the door in the
daytime and talk loud when you're
[ __ ] sleeping you know i'm walking at
six
and he's on the phone at eight talking
to people opening up the door asking me
if i'm hungry no i'm not [ __ ] hungry
i'm still coming down with that blow i
didn't [ __ ] check the goddamn morning
so when i met terry i was on the road
pretty much like i met terry in july and
a week later i went on the road to new
york
syracuse
buffalo
and i came back and i would see terry
for two or three nights i'd go on the
road
but i still live with gap
and then one time i asked terry can i
come over and do laundry i never left
that's where you make fun of me when
you're saying oh
i've been planning the movement with
paul you're like okay i just brought
laundry and never left yeah you just
bring laundry you never leave wow is
this this what's this my everything
we mean everything this is everything
let's hang it up where the heck is that
but that was a house i'll never forget i
mean i had every all my paperwork was
going over there
i didn't change my license till like 2
000 [ __ ] 10
from 2000 from 98 my license was over
there always see because if the cops
were looking for me they'd go there they
couldn't find me
yeah exactly i said at least get 20
minutes of time so what would you do
that's actually kind of interesting when
you were like acting and stuff and
living in hotels do you have like a p.o
box or what would you do i was getting
my mail there at gavin's
for years yeah sometimes i've had i had
a p.o box in boulder
i got a p.o box now
you know
but i always had a little something like
i always have gavin's
when you when you sign up with sag you
can't have a p.o box you gotta have a
physical address really what if you keep
moving then you have to put and change
your address and good luck when you
receive your channel
yeah that's 90 day turnaround bits so
the more you move the more your checks
are moving around so you got eight
checks coming through you're gonna get
four and put [ __ ] four losses and
they that takes an extra 90 [ __ ] days
so you don't get your money for 180 days
[ __ ] you uncle joey did that already i
don't move that much [ __ ]
and then you know what they do they'll
send you bills to that place
and when you don't pay them you get a
letter at your new place
they sent you a bill you didn't pay
all that dirty [ __ ]
then the insurance would do the same
thing
they'll send the bill to your old
address and when you don't pay it
don't go at a dentist
maybe
six years ago i went to the dentist and
he goes joey you get a root canal just
go down the corner tell him i sent you
he'll do it right now i'm like what are
you talking about i've never heard that
i told you a dentist do it he goes oh we
don't do that here had to get up stop
what i was doing pay the [ __ ] for what
the [ __ ] i just did and walk down a
block and a half with a smack on like an
idiot [ __ ] with somebody you know
and go to a [ __ ] dentist and he pulls
it out he goes what do you have on you
know i gave him three bills cash
i never heard from the guy again
did he do it though yeah he did it no
problem guy was great we had a great
time we giggled this [ __ ] i never heard
from the guy again he goes i don't know
what's going to cost you what do you got
now go yeah
build a difference insurance never heard
from the guy again
excuse me i'm shooting a [ __ ]
commercial for sprint the phone rings
it's a collection agency
with this [ __ ] [ __ ]
he sent the bill to like an address when
i lived in new jersey when i was before
i went to prison i swear to god
i go where'd you get that address from
me because well this is the address my
assistant found online that i came to
you in california
why would i have a [ __ ] new jersey
address
wow you motherless [ __ ] are you stupid
i made him call the credit bureau
i can't i keep having creditors sent to
me for the uh the minute the clinic that
i go to because you can't go to a dog if
you get sick here you can't go to the
doctor they say okay we can make give
you an appointment in two weeks so every
time i go
i say how much is going to be and they
they always say nothing i don't get a
bill and then i get a collection agency
notice and i have to go online and
[ __ ] pay it
that's crazy
no it's a it's a [ __ ] system man yeah i
haven't bought [ __ ] since i've been out
like with a credit card or nothing but
my credit's completely going to be good
in a year because after seven years you
got an atm card no well you gotta get an
atm card and build it up a little bit oh
yeah i mean i brought like a card to
amazon and order [ __ ] online okay
you know build up show that you you know
talk listen i'm not a spy huh in 1991
in 1993
george and i've told this story before i
couldn't go anywhere
damn oh you're on the run no
i didn't pay a credit card
oh not one of them
the only thing i did was sold the condo
everything else i [ __ ] did illegally
they got my car
they got everything american express
visa mastercard diners club discover
discover this account was closed and i
went and wrote one of those checks they
sent you when you get the card bam cash
that midnight for a thousand gebo 901
monday the bank's calling me that
account was closed we could throw you in
jail but you can't you cashed a [ __ ]
yeah that's my money that's like the
business law number one they put a check
in your mailbox that [ __ ] belongs to
you until you figure it out
it's [ __ ] crazy you can't do that
[ __ ] no more though dog i [ __ ]
everybody i couldn't go to a comedy club
like if i would [ __ ]
i have a web page for for years oh yeah
i couldn't i wouldn't advertise for
years
it got to the point where they would
know like they knew i was at the broker
and they would call the broker every
tuesday this is not even six months
after i got separated bro i'd be at the
bar and the phone would be ringing joey
for you hello hey this is bill joey
what's going on how's comedy going
listen you'll discover 800. we'll take
62.50 and they call it next tuesday we
didn't get your check
it was a five go to comedy works that
[ __ ] started calling the com but he
works that's [ __ ] crazy
a new talent night though so they were
calling the daytime there's joey there's
gonna be internet yep
and they would call me or leave a
message credit bureau and then the
[ __ ] management would give me a slip
i'm dying for my life he has an open mic
if you want to leave messages from that
i'm paying my [ __ ] bills god damn it
they're on it like so on it
it breaks your [ __ ] heart embarrasses
but that's how deep i went dog but i had
to cancel everything
i got a p.o box
in those days in boulder i started
getting letters in there they found out
where the p.o box was i just split
and i never responded to zero
huh my wife went on the computer like
two years after we were together she was
like
she's like all right let's clean this
[ __ ] up and she started writing letters
to these [ __ ] little by little
and i always kept the credit card for
250 even if it was high interest just to
show like it pay
zales always give me a cup
all right go to sales tomorrow buy
something for 300.
you know you could get 10 dollars for if
you resell it
but that's the way and everything you
buy is gonna be 42 percent interest
but who gives a [ __ ] you pay it off for
a year that comes up me a credit but
that's what i did
i had a sales card and i bought
knickknacks
for my wife and i had a [ __ ] atm card
and then i had a card for five hundred
dollars some [ __ ] [ __ ] company sent
me but every you know
maybe i was taking cash advances on that
for weed
when the weed store first opened it
would cost me [ __ ] 62 dollars to pull
out of 20. i almost went nuts damn but
that's how bad i was but you know what
dog i could walk into any [ __ ]
joint today and go yo
zero down exactly 210 a month that's how
banging the credit is bro that was 21
years ago don't even bring it up [ __ ]
i've been working
i've been trying to uh get mine better
like mine was good for a while but
exactly it's been like a little bit low
for a little bit like it dipped a little
bit that's [ __ ] up because every time
like every time you go in a new car
it's like a they check your credit so
well every time you pull up your credit
it affects you yeah
let's say you're a mutt and you think
you're cute and you go to all these
dealers to get a dollar off every time
they pull your bureau and then i know
you bet
so as soon as i rip it out i look down
and go this much been at north hollywood
he's been at glendale toyota hollywood
toyota racine toyota this guy's a bump
yeah and i'll tell him to his face don't
what's the problem here you got good
credit you're looking for a dollar off
it's over this is what you're paying for
the car you went to five places they
told you no you think we're gonna bend
your [ __ ] dummy
take the 249 well they
my cut is worth a 3800 lesson
your car's worth 1618
if i light it on fire you know what i'm
saying
that's what i'm going to give you i'm
going to sell you my car for bare bones
because people don't understand like
they're like well if you say to me well
i want
the money off
i can't give you both then i give you
the money off but then you still got to
take 18 for my car no no no no yeah
yeah i gave me 3 000 off right now you
got to give me what do you want for your
car 38 what are you going to be 18.
because i got you know what i'm saying
but people never understood that they're
like no i wanted that price and i want
38 from my car well you went to 10
[ __ ] places to go nothing
how long did you sell cars for i
remember your time i used to be a car
salesman
like a year here then i would get into
comedy and then i would feel bad about
comedy i'd do it for three months and
say what the [ __ ] am i doing how can i
have a job if i'm gonna be a comic all
together i saw cars all together maybe
three years
and was it like hourly and commission
if you get homily in commission if you
get hourly after about three months they
tell you to get the [ __ ] out of it
you're a failure
because you only get hourly when you
don't sell enough cars yeah when you
don't sell cars
i didn't even know so it's if what's
minimum wage today in california it's
like nine bucks all right so you get 40
times nine you get 360 times four
even if you work the 80 [ __ ] hours
they don't give a [ __ ]
you get paid for 40. that's part of the
training program
they give you a flat 500 a week or
something but a [ __ ] could walk up
there and make more than that the first
week
if you really put your mind it just like
anything else bro
just like anything else you know the
agostino sold those [ __ ] pens online
for a long time he was really good at it
he wasn't making bad money
he was walking out over 15 16 an hour
for five hours of work you're home by
one o'clock
but he knew that there was 30 bucks an
hour when that [ __ ] of the
agostino would have stayed another year
that's 30 bucks an hour selling pens
online that's crazy
that's [ __ ] crazy you can make a buck
50 a day
that's uh three 750 a week selling
[ __ ] pens online with the agostino
who's working 20 hours a week
and you could do go home take a nap and
go out and do comedy yeah
that's not a bad gig
it would take you a year 18 months to do
that i i i've always like
when you talk about selling cars i don't
know anything about cars you don't need
to know anything about anything
that's what people's problem is
that's where people get caught
that's why they always say a salesman
gets ruined when he gets smart
any salesman talking about any salesman
and generality any salesman i don't care
if you're selling insurance
i don't care if you're selling [ __ ]
computers i don't care if you're selling
any time you have a job on commission
you go through a big slump and that's
why people drop out
because that slump is the first month is
pure luck it's mom's mom you know that
kid that comes to your house uncle dog
my mom picked 12 out of 12 in the
football pool she won 500
let me see that [ __ ] witch do it
again
you know what i'm saying but it's always
the first one or two times my first
month in the carbon i sold 14 cars
oh [ __ ] the next month i sold like 16.
then the next
month i sold like 18. then the next
month i showed four
i got smart
i went away from what they taught me
then the fifth month i sold like six and
i got frustrated
then the sixth month i sold like five
and i quit and i went to another
dealership but i still brought the bad
habits and that dude took me back to
basics
and he explained to me that not knowing
about the car
is beneficial not knowing about the
product you know why
because now you got a reason to bring me
in
and i'm the killer inside you're the
nice guy and i'm the big bad wolf
and i tell you all the time that's what
everything whether you're selling
computers on the phone you call me like
oh let me see what my boss wants to do
yep your boss don't exist
you're the boss you're just trying to
keep your [ __ ] commission
or make the sale for a bonus
but people are very confused when it
comes to that [ __ ] because you gotta
size out the guy and see what his
buttons are
so george comes in for a [ __ ]
computer he wants to know how fast it is
he plays videos
he likes to play music on there now your
computer jargo comes into that but it's
mixed with salesmanship
okay all right i don't know much about
the computer
i don't know much about a cell phone
but let's pretend just for the sake of
arguing
i got i got a list and your name came on
at least i had for insurance
you have no insurance okay i have no
insurance
but i want a car george perez is one of
the top insurance guys
in the area in north hollywood
but not only is george perez
kind of smart
george perez knows that bird dogging is
everything
so george perez puts an ad at the coffee
shop
10 bucks an hour come to my office and
call these leads from five to seven at
night
all right
so
i come in
so if i [ __ ] sell
george if i sell insurance
right i'm not gonna get you to look at
me if i sell george
i'm not gonna [ __ ]
get you to listen to me
i gotta sell the appointment
that's the most important thing
because my job is to get george at the
door you know why because i get 10 bucks
an hour
but i get 10 every time george gets an
appointment plus
50 bucks if he sells it that night
and if i send george on 10 of those
george's gonna sell six of those
[ __ ]
i used to make more money doing that job
leave but i ever did anything else on
the phone
so you know how to move that was the
worst thing about when i got that job it
was too late in my life like i was
leaving new jersey
this job was like if i was here
and i had to walk to the fire station
it was like stealing george
the guy's like listen you want to come
in at five if you're coming from five
tonight you give me ten bucks an hour
the guy was i got an american flag on
this thing flags everywhere he wasn't he
wasn't gonna [ __ ] jew me down for a
nickel this guy
dog every week he would give me [ __ ]
cash and my head would blow up
yeah because it was 20 hours a week
and i was probably making
eight seven fifty eight hundred dollars
and i did and that was from the
beginning
like in the beginning the first week i
made like 550 650 then i lingered about
750 740
780 775 was always a straight figure to
give me a printout and [ __ ] like oh wow
because after a week i figured out it
wasn't him or whatever was the
appointment first him back to the
appointment him back to the appointment
and back to the appointment him back to
the appointment him
our agency back to the appointment you
know i'm saying so he's always back to
the appointment what time can he be
there tomorrow well i don't know what
tomorrow okay thursday night his
agenda's open he's in your neighborhood
six o'clock well i'm not sure i don't
like strangers well he can meet you at
the coffee shop
you know and i would just go and he
would get three appointments a night out
of me
that's 15 bucks you know plus the
[ __ ] 25 plus the 50 for the bonus it
was sensational guys that was money
and and so you never you never actually
sold one thing but you just made it not
one thing i just sold [ __ ]
appointments yeah
an appointment that's the most important
thing about anything you may sell you're
gonna sell one thing and you're gonna
stick with one thing
and you know one thing with sales or
anything else in life the more people i
have contact with the more i'm going to
sell
i go out to bars monday tuesday and
wednesday i'm a 25 year old good looking
guy
i do steroids i got a nice little job at
sprint i live in my mother's basement
but it's dude it up i can [ __ ] chicks
over there i got a car i'm making 220 a
month it's got the chinese rims
firecrackers come on you know what i'm
saying i go out every night i know one
thing that i didn't know at [ __ ] 20.
and i didn't know this at 30. i figured
it out when i was too old and too
[ __ ] ugly that the more women you
talk to the more women you're going to
sleep with
when you go to a bar if you're a pig and
you just keep talking to girls how are
you you asked 10 of them for the phone
number how many of them are going to
give me your number just drop the cup
four of them
just sell tinder you're on tinder give
me a shot
i'm not creeping i'm from the
neighborhood i lived down the corner
i've lived here all my life
where'd you go to high school my morning
i went to north bernie let's do this
together right or wrong creepy dudes get
numbers and they put them in their phone
and at night after they do three lines
of coke they start calling those numbers
guess what they went out three nights
and they got 30 [ __ ] numbers
somebody's coming over to polish my
helmet
where's tony better that lee
dirty numbers somebody's coming over
i can't imagine getting 30 numbers in a
weekend that's crazy because a hitter
knows the more numbers
it sells
we got more stars
you do
50 milligrams those little cantaloupes
that 150 they got
sure why not
i'm good
i'm high sure
let me give some shout outs real quick
my main men david
neverez
paul nolan steamboat willie
crystal johnson my little savage over in
utah sending black salmon shirts
amy another one or two
avon otto
kevin hortoff
and punch drunk podcast
those [ __ ] always out there
banging out from jason tebow to sam
tripley
to my brother [ __ ] uh what's
his name all right hari shaffer
was the guy in denver the guy in dallas
used to follow him is irish referral
coming with you this time no irish
referee stayed home making [ __ ]
swirls what the [ __ ] i don't know
how long have you known ari like 12 13
years
yeah from the comedy store he was really
young and he answered the phones and
[ __ ] like that
and no matter what position i was in i
always liked talking to those guys you
know because i wanted to see what they
were going through you know
you don't really know how bad you got it
till you talk to somebody you know and
you think you got it bad you know brian
holtzman one night i told brian holzer i
can't [ __ ] believe i'm down here
[ __ ]
130 spot and he goes you don't want the
spot don't do it put a sign up
you don't want the spot at 1 30. see how
many people sign up for that [ __ ]
spot
yeah you'll learn your lesson that's the
reals that's the reals we don't know how
good we got it so
you know uh it's good to see what you're
doing listen man
it's good that you're out of the system
because you know bro once you get in
that system oh my god jesus christ and
people have no idea we talk all the time
on this [ __ ] in the show
once you get in the system then bad luck
takes over
like you did something stupid but then
after that bad luck always has a weird
way of showing up
you know like your cousin comes over he
needs a ride they can announce a blow
he'll give you an eight ball
boom the guy who delivered to the cops
of that it's got nothing to do with you
then you get a case of bad luck then
you're out on bail everything's going
good and now you need money to pay the
attorney that place used to rob all the
time stereos now you go there's a silent
alarm as you're coming out
they don't really get you they get your
car and now you're gonna explain it's
just a case of bad luck then where you
live [ __ ] they throw you out because
you haven't paid the rent then bad luck
takes over then eventually you end up in
the [ __ ] system
and that's that's the reals in the
beginning it's bad luck mixed with a bad
mistake
you know okay listen
i'm wrong sometimes people get a gun and
go into a gas station and shoot a clerk
the first time that's [ __ ] up you know
but 9 out of 10 those people have done
something before
they just didn't wake up one [ __ ] day
and say i'm going to go get a gun and
again thanks [ __ ]
a complete different style of [ __ ]
lunacy you know
i can't imagine going on like i've been
thinking about it
a little bit but
sometimes i even worry i'm like i don't
know what would happen because anyone
can have a bad night like what if i had
a [ __ ] crazy bad night and then some
like it could happen
like someone shooting you with the gun
i don't know like people always say if
you get stuff like that it attracts it
so i don't know but then again you see i
don't know if you saw that video that uh
uh i don't know if it was a store or a
house
but three people broke in and then yeah
the chick had a gun and she killed it
she killed tomorrow that was great so
that's i was like [ __ ] yeah maybe i do
need a son
we've said it before on the show only a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
today wouldn't at one time think of
getting a gun for your home and your
safety and your family hell yeah
when you drive down your street and you
see that guy in your corner or you drive
down the street and notice that your
light bulb is out in front of your
building
there's so many little things and you
know what man there's so many people
that are willing to do something
somebody was telling me in jersey a few
weeks ago
a guy got murdered because a gang went
out that night
and said something if you give him high
beams shoot him
oh man you know [ __ ] like that you never
know no more guys no it's true but you
know what the situation is the other day
i'm in new york and i'm sitting there
and i'm waiting to get a cab and you
know what i just want to sit there and
breed the city
you ever just want to sit somewhere and
breathe a city a particular situation
enjoy them sitting there watching i go
you know what what would happen
if right now [ __ ] alibaba pulled up
here and took his jacket off and said
for the name of christ i'm killing
myself
with joey diaz with george perez with
lisa immediately pull out a gun and
shoot the guy in the head
would you be that cool common collector
before he pulled the trigger which he's
going to pull because
it's scott's tape to his [ __ ] hand
or glued to his hand his glove unless
unless i was just training which i think
if i if i got a gun i'd have to go get
training like that beside do you know
what goes through your heart
i'd bust a cap in his [ __ ] ass
i know you would george
but for most people yeah they ain't been
where we've been they don't got our
training it's the reactions
okay yes okay
in those situations when you when
you know i go to a place and i sit there
for 10 minutes and i'm going to see
something that's [ __ ] up that lee
wouldn't even dream of seeing
i'm not saying 10 minutes i'm
exaggerating let's say an hour if i sit
on a new york city corner on a stoop
eating a hot dog and reading the paper
and just watch in one hour i will see
something illegal two things illegal
that lee will not say
you know i know body language
i know how fast you walk
you know why because i did it
if i see you walk by twice i know what
you're doing oh yeah looking at
something
you know how you look at me
to see if i'm watching you
where you stop
you know it's this things people do that
you go hold on one second this guy's up
there no good
and people like me who just have no
reference for it it just doesn't even it
doesn't even uh it's not a fault it's
that you're not used to that but we
don't even really see that yeah unless i
come up to you and then go lead listen
we're gonna start looking at aspiration
i say to you one day lee we're gonna
start a book making operation okay all
right me and georgia will work the
phones and the blackboard
she's gonna work the phones i need you
to just sit outside
get a chair
read the paper and every 20 minutes take
a walk
well i'll walk where
i go
get a dog i don't give a [ __ ] what you
do
take a walk because
some days you're gonna take a walk over
there some nights you're gonna take a
walk over there
you can't take the car because you can't
leave the post
but pretty soon you're gonna pick up
things to look at you're going to see
that that guy that's been in the car for
22 minutes why is he in this car
he's going to see that cop car that
drove around twice
you're going to learn that my lawnmower
cars how they come around
it's really crazy that's how i learned
i wanted julio rodriguez to call in here
a couple weeks ago he was opening up a
blue jiu jitsu school
he's sort of a cousin to me and when
they were on the phone about a month ago
and i asked him a question i remember we
were young kids we used to have to go to
harlem in the bronx on saturdays
and work for our mutual friend he was
maybe three years older than me julio
and his brother was sandwich
when we were like 10 sandwich weighed
[ __ ] 300 pounds already and so he
loved sandwiches so he called him
sandwich sandwich because he was puerto
rican sandwich yeah and i would go to
catholic school
and when i come home on friday nights if
i go to my mom and go ma i saw this
bicycle
go work for cheryl tomorrow
he'll give you 50 bucks for the day yeah
i don't want to work your channel go to
the channel
and i would go they pick you up in the
morning take you into howard johnson's
eat breakfast and then you shoot into
the boogie down bronx you go upstairs
they start sending you for stuff listen
go get two chickens a pound of rice you
know you're the assistant to the cook
and from there you gotta go to this
guy's house and pick up money then they
gotta go this guy's i'll combine you
know this guy when you go down that
corner and next you know it's six
o'clock at night bro when you're [ __ ]
ten somebody gives you 50 bucks and a 20
bonus what
yeah i would go right to my mother's bar
and [ __ ] go let's go to the toy store
i'm going to
go home and take a shower and go to
sleep you got to do it again tomorrow
[ __ ] oh yeah i would do it
saturdays and sundays how many kids were
there like you who do four or five
puerto rican kids in the neighborhood
they just have an army of kids doing all
the deliveries and all around deliveries
running go run this 50 bucks to don dona
over there 114th street you know what
she is yeah take one of the kids with
you
and you walk over there and nobody would
[ __ ] with you because they know who you
work for
nobody really messed with you because
they knew you were running numbers for
channel that day
how did they find out they just knew the
neighborhood they knew that that's a
that's a numbers listen the numbers
brackets in the 70s were very simple you
have a bodega
okay and that bodega it's two guys
working
and there's a phone and there's a couple
sodas in the [ __ ] thing there's a
couple of old pancakes there for sale
but there's a gallon or two of milk but
they're not really what they are you're
going in there's a book of dreams
and you give the guy three dollars last
night i had a dream that my cat ate a
snake there's a there's a thing in there
about a cat even a snake so it's number
54. so now you got to put a number in
front of it or a number behind it what's
your lucky number george seven 754 what
do you want to do
you know uh
straighten box
all right and then you give them the
number
they get they write it on a yellow piece
of paper that has a pink and a white
sheet behind it
the white sheet from the bottom this is
right in the street
this is right on 118 [ __ ] street in
1970 this has to be
knight that's pretend 1974.
it would be next it would be a chinese
restaurant next would be a tailor next
it would be a kid's toy store and right
there in the heart of harlem right down
118th street would be charles bodega
okay so jail would take those numbers so
right away you waited
you gave the white sheet to the customer
you took the pink sheet and the yellow
sheet went upstairs
they had to make it upstairs by three
o'clock
so let's say i was assigned to you that
day all i did was sit with lee while he
wrote those numbers out
and every time you got 20 slips i ran
upstairs
if you had if i had over cash i'd give
it to you you'd run upstairs
if i need milk you go get it
if i need for you because there's no
phones
they wouldn't use the phone downstairs
so you would have to be all day going up
and down but you didn't give a [ __ ] you
were 10.
they were treating you like an adult
people yeah that was awesome back then
people let you see their guns
people letting you answer the phone and
write the number the first time they let
me answer the phone
and i said 88 32 10 bucks 10 bucks
straight my dick got hot i said i was
making the big time
i had a similar experience my dad worked
at legal seafoods and i answered the
phone at the uh
mail order department
it's crazy that we had similar ones but
you took numbers at 10 years old and you
had to run them and they teach you how
to run them and then who hit the number
because then you have to break down the
numbers let's say five three four came
out there's people that are so poor
they'll put three numbers on five three
dollars on five
that three dollars my member pays you
18.50 for the day and you're an old lady
on social security and you gamble that
same five every day
i know where you live i don't give a
[ __ ] it takes you two minutes to run it
over there and keep her happy and she'll
give me a dollar tip
i would also get tips
when i delivered money sometimes 50
cents
sometimes 25 cents but i never got
mugged
i always knew and then some days they
just put you on the street
go outside just walk around that means
look for cars
any cars that don't belong there after
two weeks you'll know what cars belong
in that block and what cars don't belong
on that block what would happen if there
was a car that didn't belong go upstairs
and let them know there's a black car
with three cops in it yeah all right who
is that uh that could be henry did he
have a beard yeah it's henry [ __ ] him we
gave him 500 last monday time to go [ __ ]
his mother
and then they would send you downstairs
to go downstairs and tell the guy at the
bodega not to let henry up today
we gave you five last week and then we
gave the chief commander five what the
[ __ ] do you want get the [ __ ] out of
here sometimes they were cool and you
let them up for a meal
because a lot of times on saturdays the
bookies would cook
a big [ __ ] meal neighborhood people
come upstairs like they were cool it
couldn't be anybody because there's
money
couldn't be anybody so the cops would
come up from what every once in a while
shake hands hey eat a ball
we'll see you next tuesday cool man some
of them will place a bet
wow better number
[ __ ] interesting [ __ ] like that so i
wanted him to call in
and just you know talk about that for a
while yeah it's kind of crazy what you
see as again i loved it it was legal
in my world that [ __ ] was legal i walked
around with a badge of honor
because they paid the cops it didn't
really matter what do you mean in your
world it was legal it was legal in my
world at that age that [ __ ] was legal
jack nobody got bothered nobody got
stabbed nobody got all addiction and
those guys made
tons of money in those days
20 30 grand a day taking dollar numbers
are you [ __ ] kidding me i got picket
numbers the other day in fact you got to
find me the new jersey
picket results for saturday
the 24th of september
give me the [ __ ] three numbers and
the pick four i guarantee i hit one of
those [ __ ]
just because i roll like that new jersey
what pick new jersey lottery uh results
picket lottery results
see what you get there
okay
i forgot that there was a [ __ ] little
chinese guy close to the hotel and he
takes numbers he sells rolling papers i
bought easy waters and big bamboo to
bring back the talk [ __ ]
what what what the easy one is a little
too [ __ ] thick
oh
yeah is it like alcohol easy water no
it's rolling papers oh i grew up on easy
water and big bamboo
oh no bamboo like chichen chang yeah but
then they threw out big bamboo nobody
could smoke a big bang boo john i used
to smoke those thai joints in the 80s
and pass out for eight hours what'd you
finally say the pick three yeah eight
o'clock pick three pick four or one give
me the pick three first for which day
september 23rd saturday okay or 24th
double check 24th okay what do you got
so for the pick two you had i don't want
to pick two i want the pick three and
the pick four sorry pick three and pick
four evening or midday give me the
evening
six two four for the pick three
six two four for the pick three where's
the pick four
who pick four's a good one with seven
eight seven zero hold on let's check it
out
i get ten percent
dick
you did nothing you heard
you get ten percent i'm the one that had
to walk two [ __ ] hours to put this
number in that's what's up the [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with i do another
respect for my mom i got about one
number right
so what came out six two four
on the evening yes sir and what was the
midday
902
and what was the midday pick for
zero zero two six and what was the
evening pick for
seven eight seven zero
all right let me tell you what i had
this [ __ ] dummy
209 came out
nine or two i know two i had two one
nine straight in box
six
24 came up yeah i had 604 straighten box
and i had 517 straighten box
but i had mercy 18 13 straighten box and
one eight one three straighten box
i'm a sucker but i still gotta go in
there out of respect so does that mean
you won something yeah i won dick i won
nothing
i won the dick that's what i want oh i
thought it was close so i thought you
know 6 24 came out i got 604
and [ __ ] uh
219 was the evening
5-1-7 my mom paid my mom played 604 and
517 every [ __ ] day in our life
through brooklyn
three different venues five dollars a
piece
you don't [ __ ] around he's saying what
are you looking at me like that four
o'clock second
how much is the win on that back in
those days
today if i wanted to pick three i'm
lucky if i pick up 250 if i bet 50 cents
now in those days if i put five dollars
on a number i picked up 2 500 at five
o'clock damn
if i put
250 on the number
i picked up uh 12.50
damn
if you bought a dollar on a number you
got 500 cash at five o'clock the
government didn't know nobody knew your
wife didn't know
it didn't come out of the paper then
direct deposit into your [ __ ]
checking account so everybody would bet
a dollar in the neighborhood how many
people in the neighborhood i know now
you got people who trust you who call
you every day from [ __ ] jersey and go
hey
oh can you bet some numbers in for me
beautiful i got credit yeah let's do it
give me 604 straighten box five dollars
give me five seventeen straight bucks
five dollars give me four four four five
dollars straight in the box give me
[ __ ] 8 29 it's
it was really a tremendous business that
new jersey lottery came along and all
these victories yeah and that was the
end of that and you can still take
numbers
i guarantee you and i today
could open up a numbers bank in harlem
and clear
12.50 a week after we pay expenses
what's expenses
brick wall but the payoffs would be
brutal yeah
the payoffs in today's [ __ ] criminal
enterprise and the bronx and [ __ ] would
be brutal
but there's still a market because you
still have all those old those people
that were there when i were a kid were
now adults they grew up in it when you
grow up in it it's completely different
you know michael vick grew up in dog
fighting you know what that meant that
when he went to school some days he saw
people dog fight
he saw people kicking a dog and it was
natural to them
i grew up with that it was natural to me
are you disappointed that you couldn't
do that more as an adult
i'm gonna tell you something
i did it
when i left after i robbed michael
jewelers
and i went to new jersey and i left new
jersey
i tried to get my life together and i
actually called him and started doing it
before i went to colorado i was i ran
numbers from december to april 25th
and i like doing it the first three
months
but at that time i knew one thing about
it that the bubble was gonna break
let me tell you something what are you
gonna do one day yeah
let's say when i got promoted and i
would have started getting a thousand
dollars a week
that's 36 thousand dollars a year cash
that nobody knows about eventually i
gotta get a part-time job
to you know what i'm saying to cover
my [ __ ] rent and all this [ __ ]
but what am i gonna do
at the end of [ __ ] 10 years
what am i i mean i'm never going to go
to jail for this not in new york in
those days you got a ticket
but let's pretend at 28 i quit who's
going to hire me
you can't put it on the resume yeah
that's your question george perez where
you been
yeah where you been
what have you been doing mucking around
the neighborhood
you know it's not going to [ __ ] work
out for you my friend and i was always
scared of that like i have enough zeros
in my [ __ ] life at that time when i
was 19 i went to colorado i had a nice
job over there
i was gonna get [ __ ] killed over
there eventually he didn't take a
[ __ ] genius in colorado no in ger
over in new york where i was going to
118th over there okay because i was
starting to get
credit from people for weed they knew i
worked for jail
you know everybody was [ __ ] like
hunky dory and i saw the beginning of it
and i'm like
you know coke wasn't
bursting out of the seams over there yet
it was just weed and like uh
you know you want to take an ounce
of this chocolate time i would sit there
and go oh if i take that out i'm never
coming back yeah this poor black guy is
never going to see my [ __ ] white ass
again
you know
there's a part of me that has to say
that
when i was doing that craziness i
enjoyed it and like this little part to
me that say i missed
that lifestyle but i gotta tell you
something there's other parts to me that
i don't miss none of that [ __ ] it was
fun while it lasted
but i couldn't go to that the only thing
i could do today if all this comedy
stopped and podcasting and i had to make
a living i would get a part-time job
telemarketing or something like that
and i would have to start booking nfl
basketball ufc
and i would do it in a nice big way that
i could make myself
five six thousand a week
and that's
it i can pull that off it would take a
year to pull that off but it'd be stress
as well with the internet just
it's tough to to get a bookmaking
operation [ __ ] especially if you're
smart and out of the game and you change
your phone it costs a little extra
that's all i have friends that do it for
[ __ ] 10 years
20 years it costs a little extra to
change phones
move locations you know
and then it's like lease well how can
you sell drugs lee you get the same
people
i trust george
if i trade can't george if i pay him
when he wins
and he pays me on time if i cut him
slack from time to time let him put a
big bet and george ain't going nowhere
else he'd be [ __ ] crazy
the way he gambles they'd break his leg
somewhere else
so stay with me i'm not gonna break your
legs you've been a customer for 20 years
you get into a bind we work it out we
make payments until we put it together
and you keep those customers late and
next thing you know you're running you
do this 20 years you got the same
customers lee and they pay on time they
know the schedule they know you you know
them you know their kids and there you
go now the people who you pick up during
the year they're
they're [ __ ] cherry so back then
could there be like one in the
neighborhood who he just had an
apartment and he didn't do anything else
he was the neighborhood i grew up with
15 of those [ __ ] guys
christ then there's guys that have jobs
and part of their job is being around
another hundred guys every day
so at lunch time they go to a bar and
everybody knows that's the guy if you
want to place a number or that's the guy
you want to put it better yeah you have
to well that's the guy that gives you
money if you get the gambling problem or
that's the guy that gets into trouble
that's a guy that gives you money if you
get into cat life trouble you got to
move you need to deposit you go over
there you talk to george what do you
need i need a thousand bucks i like you
george it's gonna cost you 1300. so for
10 weeks i want you to give me 130. yeah
i could live with that he took care of
me
it's fair
it's [ __ ] fair
people call it loan sharky
i think it's fair a bank would do the
same to you
because the bank will charge you if you
do the paperwork a bank will charge you
yeah but joey they charged me 10 gold
did they do the [ __ ] financing fee or
submitting the credit app fee or the
[ __ ] finger in the ass fee by the
time you get those three fees you might
as well pay george the money and move on
with your [ __ ] life you just save
three hours of aggravation at the bank
waiting for the call the [ __ ]
paperwork your credit radio goes down
your credit rating
[ __ ]
lee you're [ __ ] up aren't you i'm a
little bit higher look at you it's fun
you know why because you dick around all
week and you do those [ __ ] doses
50 what 850 milligrams
i did two you did 850 milligrams let me
ask you a question
when was the last time 850 [ __ ]
milligrams was anything for you
never why would you even insult me
number one and assault yourself
you know 850 don't do dick did you see
me doing 850 in [ __ ] new york out of
respect for you i opened up with a
thousand and i did four [ __ ] more
like a lunatic i slept like a baby then
saturday night 1800 saturday night i was
eating stones like they were going out
of style i wasn't bringing those
[ __ ] back
i kept popping them like [ __ ] yum yum
pills
there was a bag of [ __ ] 20 i only
left five at the house for the flight
and i ate those right at the airport
with breakfast like you would have been
proud of me on an empty stomach you had
a thousand with breakfast like that on
an empty stomach and then i put
breakfast over it
i ate five of them right before i walked
through security
and as i made the turn my flight was at
7
and it was six o'clock on the dot
and you're not gonna believe what
happened
what happened i had a protein shake
at the [ __ ] uh it took me 30 minutes
to get from the hotel to the county
airport i always drink a little protein
shake and i had a half a bite of a
protein ball
just to get the sensation away in the
morning so i wouldn't get carsick
it wasn't george perez god was on my
corner that morning it's a five and a
half hour flight ain't got enough good
food on the [ __ ] plane you know
i walk into an airplane i'm looking for
a yummy i'm standing somebody's gonna
take good care of me alimento like
spanish people say i don't wanna tuna
sandwich i don't want subway sandwich i
don't wanna rap
i a rap a rapper you're gonna die in
five hours [ __ ] those peanuts will not
hold you and as i might to make the turn
right before my very eyes
there was a palm restaurant
in the airport selling steak and eggs
for twenty one dollars
with little cubed potatoes and wheat
toast and a fruit cup i said take the
potatoes shove them up your ass
throw me the [ __ ] fruit cup i went in
there guess what i had my wallet
a palms card bingo i have one and i
don't think they have one in l.a anymore
what airline is it for
oh man i'm gonna have to play delta now
somewhere damn just to go again i said
that [ __ ] i had this half retail
waitress waiter he didn't know what
country he was in i said listen pablo i
don't give a [ __ ] what you're thinking
i'm thinking of steak well done with two
eggs sunny side and then two pieces of
wheat toast
i had a fruit cup i was sitting there my
leg was tapping he was like a mexican
magician within minutes
he came out with a [ __ ] beautiful
steak
i ate that [ __ ] rant to that
plain dog
with a protein shake so he an egg i had
the protein shake in that one before the
steak that's as i'm saying so
i don't want to be hungry on a plane no
that no
and that food sometimes you eat the
fruit
sometimes you eat i don't want to eat
the bun with the [ __ ] butter that
biscuits terrible
everything is [ __ ] terrible on that
thing every once in a while you catch a
break i'm not gonna lie to you some a
couple weeks ago i caught a good break
with airline food it wasn't bad
but besides that you're always like owen
creed george perez what the [ __ ] i could
bring you on here you were dead mute
tonight what happened nothing you come
on here you're singing opera songs in
spanish and [ __ ] you got the accordion
no i'm high as [ __ ] right good good good
good good
i'm high i'm chilling listening it's
crazy i'm not surprised all these good
things going on in your life bro you're
one of the true ones you know
there used to be a latino comedy scene
it just evaporated yeah if anybody was a
part of it my all-time favorite night
was that those monday nights
at the sunset room at the sunshine room
where is that that's hacienda heights
hacienda heights with the chinese
restaurant that don't serve white people
and the [ __ ] donut shop with the
chinese people
you know that mon that that comedy that
place could be
[ __ ] huge they need two of those fix
the stage put a spotlight in the corner
it was friday saturdays and monday
nights workout tonight no you're right
people will come back i'm all
lobster tails one lobster tails were
black on the bottom they were
pre-katrina
they took those the lobster tails they
had there on monday night
with lobster tails that got hit with oil
and the early [ __ ] and awesome they
went to the bottom and they died
remember all these lobster tails if you
picked them up they were kind of spooky
like
i don't know what juan is selling me
over here this ain't regular on monday
nights it's 14.95 why would you order
the lobster i never ordered the [ __ ]
tail what are you [ __ ] i just looked
at what the guy had next to me and when
he got up i looked underneath
just to see if there remember mum he
used to have lobster instead yeah yeah
lobster and steak lobster steak night is
that thursdays
what the [ __ ] you think because he would
always do like impromptu shows hey get
some guys together come on thursday
clops tonight
the [ __ ] we did dog
the [ __ ] we did in the name of comedy
for a couple [ __ ] dollars
it's insane it really remember the
sandwich spot i had that you like that
spot too roscoe's a [ __ ] sandwich but
yeah my [ __ ] sandwich spot and they
had comedy there yeah it would get
packed
liam i gotta tell you it was a good
sandwich there i just had one he just
came to one of my shows like about seven
yeah he always hits me up and says joey
i like to come bring you guys boom bring
me a sandwich done
yeah you want to say he'll even answer
you want a sandwich [ __ ] you surprise me
roast beef on top of turkey with salami
and [ __ ]
a juice tongue and [ __ ] feet and
lettuce and [ __ ] tomato what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] he's got eight ounces of
meat on the sandwich or you you gotta
take everything off and just eat the
turkey like a fat [ __ ] look i don't want
no most people think
are you still on any paroles any
probation nah i've been off of
everything i'm trying to get my passport
right now because i'm finally off full
height control so what do they
what story are they telling you
uh they're telling me yeah
but like you know i don't owe child
support but like i still have a little
like back pay so they're like they're
trying to get money out of me so i think
i'm just gonna have to like give them
more money
and uh now before you pay anything call
again because california adds interest
that you don't have to pay that's their
own interest yes so if they say 60 check
it's 1400. oh yeah and you're like what
the [ __ ] i don't know come down here
give me 1400 would disappear at 60
you're like okay
so always check that out but that was a
big thing when i had a couple years ago
somebody hired me in canada they called
me a week before they go they won't let
you through and i go what's the problem
and i go is it the
felonies or the child support and they
go i think it's both okay because she
put uh whatever on you once they put
that stupidity on you you're done you
look like a [ __ ] convicted felon yeah
they just got mine taken off maybe five
years ago yeah i i got mine taken off
right when i got out of prison because
like it's weird like the child support
went after me in prison and i was like
how am i supposed to pay you i'm in
[ __ ] prison
so i had to get out i think they just do
that so they make you go and report to
them again
does it accrue when you're in prison
does it what dude yeah yeah that's how
they do it they don't give a [ __ ] that
you're in prison that's your problem
we want entrance it's gonna cost you
every [ __ ] month
[ __ ]
that's crazy
so buddy yeah i got all that off i mean
i want to go to canada man i it looks
like no you're in no danger
yeah you're in no danger they won't let
you encounter you they had a dui
so you [ __ ]
never i don't know you got a petition
that keith richards got in snoop dogg
gets in yeah he just there's a loop you
have to go to an attorney and pay an
attorney that's what i'm thinking when
he finds a [ __ ] loophole for you see
my problem is to uh found the warren in
seattle
so if you have any warrants anywhere
they won't let you in there
yeah i mean because i'm done i already
paid my debt i'm off parole i'm
i'll ask
it took me maybe four years after i got
off everything to stop being
cop paranoid
what is this
anytime you saw a copy just freak out i
got taken off
probation when i was because i i got a
reconsideration they put me in
community corrections
which means you're in a work release
program a halfway house
something
and that was the last sentence but they
they they lowered the sentence but they
gave me a longer probation
so they put you like in a men's home in
a men's home like i don't
was women there too and people watched
tv and people mingled it was tremendous
did you guys have like rules there
curfew and all that everything [ __ ] we
had furloughs that yeah
that was before the guy one word forever
that was the guy that was before the guy
went off the reservation in boston and
killed somebody yeah the next year they
stopped getting like when i got out they
stopped getting froze i was like ooh
but it was a scam
george
because you walked in there as a trainee
for a week or two
you only were allowed out in the daytime
to get a job then once you got a job and
you paid rent and you were caught up by
rent you're up to level two
once you complete your therapies and you
maintain the job for 90 days you got put
up to level three level three wasn't bad
friday and saturday that's 11 o'clock
oh and did your rent go down as your
levels went up no 75 dollars a week
then level four you got to be spotless
you were allowed to drive oh wow
midnight on fridays and saturdays and
one furlough
[ __ ]
guess who made it to level four
moira with nothing but [ __ ] and
champ did you have a car i had a [ __ ]
job selling cars so they gave me a demo
are you kidding me
but i got that february and i was level
four by like june nobody could believe
it because my attorney said if you get
the level four i'll get you out and
re-release
and i was i was at level four for like
two months living like a doctor
and then one then i figured out that
these invics
can't [ __ ]
go out unless they pay the rent but they
scammed them choice they would make them
pay the rent on thursday everybody knows
you get paid on friday oh wow so they
would save the rent's not paid by seven
o'clock on thursday you can't go out for
the weekend
you can't see your family that type of
[ __ ] so i felt bad for them but at the
same time papa needs to get paid i got a
baby on the way damn it's a mess have
you ever been convicted of a felony yes
took some advice from my own professor
all dressed up and polyester i said
listen i'll give you 75 for like 110
98 i don't know what i was charging
but you got to give it to me on friday
george i was getting 10 guys lining up
and i would give me 75 bucks to pay the
rent and then they would give me
interest on friday
yeah just so they can go out all the way
so they could go out they would pay me
anything
okay i get them for like 25 bucks a
piece 10 dudes every friday i had that
operation
then i figured out that i could [ __ ]
sell coke in there since i was level
four they wouldn't search me or piss me
they never had dogs
i could just sign it and walk right
through the [ __ ] gate that's exactly
what i would do and i would triple the
prices on that [ __ ] and cut it for those
[ __ ] they would go crazy yeah
you're taking a big risk that's a big
chance they gotta pay for that
i was terrible at rehabilitation but you
know what dog
they nailed me in there i thought it was
cute and they nailed me they took me to
court
they let me go out and they put me back
in for like 90 days they [ __ ]
tormented my life they caught you oh
once they broke me out yeah because four
guys came up positive these
[ __ ] would tweak and walk
around the halfway house shaven there
was one dude that was shaved for eight
hours and the counselor finally said how
long can you shave for
he was sweating profusely so he would
put the shower on
and sit in front of the mirror maybe the
shape and they count every out wow guy
kept coming and going what are you
shaving for oh i like to be thorough
okay
five hours later you're still shaving
you're still sweating profusely
something's gotta be it then they would
walk around at night so they pissed a
bunch of them four people were negative
for cocaine positive they knew something
was going on somebody's bringing it in
i'm walking in there with a suit
i got jewelry on i'm eating [ __ ]
breakfast ouch
the food that you pay for like it was 75
rent but 25 was groceries yeah they give
you frozen pizzas and
polka dots and oatmeal i would give it
away they go what you eat [ __ ] that not
that [ __ ] yeah so people started getting
pissed and somebody [ __ ] ratted me
out eventually and they searched for
about it that day i don't bring nothing
on me it
is the day they put me over and put me
in the bathroom to search my balls like
what are you people looking for
just tell me i'll help you out well
country man is being smuggled in a
couple people pointed at me what the
[ __ ]
i'm a community counselor because by
that time i was like a [ __ ] i
represented the third floor that type of
[ __ ]
you remember
negotiations yeah like whenever there
was quarries people would have to come
to me and i'd make them fill out a
report and then like how long was this
this isn't the person like six months
before it took me about three months to
get fired then after i came up positive
twice with cocaine they call it the
house mouse the houseman no i wasn't the
house mouse i was every floor every
floor had a they didn't want 20 people
down there going dog i didn't get my
pizza
okay dog i didn't get my [ __ ] this
dog how come i'm not getting mail so
they they didn't want people coming to
the gate so i think they would knock off
five dollars a week of rent
if i took all the grievances it wasn't
worth it georgia was yeah
i was just because if he became the
the whatever floor i had a partner i was
in one build i was in one apartment and
he was in the other so either one of us
always had to be able to re be reached
so they would come to you with like dog
i didn't get a pizza this week what do
you want me to tell you you gotta fight
with the kitchen
i want to follow my [ __ ] grievous
cause i pay for groceries and [ __ ] the
pizza should be involved in that list of
groceries father grievous
so they just didn't want to deal with it
so they would give me this [ __ ] that job
lasted three months that wasn't worth
the five hours a week though
hell not everybody because it
it's run by a bunch of other convicts as
well it's not gonna be ranked correct
i've never been in a halfway house
i heard of them though i was one in
boulder colorado this was a country club
oh yeah this was a country club they had
girls on on every floor
you know you're putting girls on every
floor with convicts and they only come
up to the floor once an hour
and if you come up to the third floor
again we pay somebody five bucks go by
the [ __ ] door and you're here when
they come up to the second floor and let
us know we'll knock on the door and
johnny will tell him not to stop [ __ ]
patrice it was a chick that was [ __ ]
everybody in the halfway house oh crazy
my name was patrice
twining and you want me to tell you
something she was hot as [ __ ]
and she was in there and the six or
seven months i was in there
she definitely slept with 20 dudes
and sucked dirty dicks she was the real
deal and her boyfriend her husband was
in jail
like doing he was like somewhere he had
nine years left and i'm like what does
he think
he knows i love him this is just part
time i mean she was a [ __ ] animal
what part time but that's what you got
to do man nobody really knows that life
to you and i wasn't involved in that
life yeah but when you go in there and
you see people the funny you were saying
something funny before you said that you
turned your life around you know
you kids what about the guys
look at the pictures of the wall on the
kids
four kids and [ __ ] i picture that wife
who could scare bed [ __ ] i mean this
woman could stop bird [ __ ] midair she's
in such bad shape
and he'll sit there at night and go man
i love my [ __ ] kids
you like how long you've been in for 10
years
yeah how long y'all left 18 years what
are you talking about
you didn't think about that before you
went to [ __ ] jail about these four
[ __ ] kids
i never understood that listen i'd get
in trouble i could get in trouble when i
didn't have jackie and terry
trouble was always working now i want my
best [ __ ] behavior
straight up
yeah like now you can just like i
couldn't imagine george yeah you can
just hit anybody now and you're getting
busted
i mean i'm glad someone didn't have a
cell phone when this should happen the
way i beat that dude up they would have
gained me way more time
18 minutes 18 months later three years
later two years later the dude saw you
on show time
no it was on mtv mtv you couldn't have
worse and good luck at the same [ __ ]
time
that is [ __ ] crazy you come up on tv
the guy's sitting there he's going to
the computer america's most wanted
where's this george perez that good
googly movie all of a sudden some show
your mama comes on he's like let me
watch it
oh [ __ ] that's the gakka that jumped me
and [ __ ]
yeah but you know what it was the best
day of your life if you look at it now
i mean
i had to i had to suffer to get where
you know i didn't have to suffer i put
myself in a spot where uh i could either
go down or say you know i don't want to
come back here again and that's what i
did i accepted what i did and i'm
[ __ ]
i know right from wrong now and i know
the consequence from right from wrong
because back then i just didn't know the
consequence
i didn't know like you know i'll get
away with this so now i know and
oh
i'm going back
25 years ago we went to a bar
and me and george got into an argument
with lee
two punches would get thrown three
punches
and then everybody would leave and maybe
george would get mad and come back but
you know what
anymore guys you do not know who you're
dealing with anymore what no
it's not worth the aggravation
you know you walk into a bar you see
four dudes and you think they're a
little off and you go and get involved
and you shoot pool and do drugs with
those guys and flash cash you're going
down yeah you're going down you have to
assume you're going down yeah dude i
remember one time we were at a bar in
montebello and i was with this big tall
[ __ ] and we went with boy we went
with girls and he was one of their
cousins
and there was another fool in the
restroom that's trying to holler at his
cousin and i guess that's that she said
no
and that foe was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] so
this guy took it upon himself to punch
these dudes in the restroom he's like
six five
and his whole neighborhood's in that bar
we got jumped so [ __ ] bad i remember
one of my friends we had a carry that
full outside so
sometimes you just [ __ ] with the wrong
person and it comes and
i'm glad now that we walked away from
that [ __ ] i got my ass flipped that did
you ever have your ass whip like that
three or four times ago
one time in music at the [ __ ] senior
prom thing
the senior thing when they give out the
awards most likely to drop out
most likely to be a junkie and all that
[ __ ]
we got into a brawl there and i stepped
into a piece of glass
i got hit in the head
you know if it wasn't for a friend of
mine that's dead now he [ __ ] bastard
a guy and then broke ahead i would make
[ __ ] dead
another time in colorado at a bar fight
that i had nothing to do with
that night i drew punches
and then six guys jumped me because they
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
you live and you learn i got by before i
got into a fight in prison where the guy
[ __ ] punched me a couple times in the
[ __ ] head then there was another
situation where i got a guy inbound to
this ball hell i got his body i got him
by the hair and i wrapped it around both
he couldn't go nowhere nah i caught him
with the laundry basket he had the
laundry basket and i hated this
[ __ ] like this caught him with
the laundry thing and i [ __ ] banged
his head off the thing
listen man you learn from everything i
don't have the energy
or the age or anything today
would it be different if i was 30. you
know what i'm saying this is the things
we say now
because we've been in those situations
it's tough to convince somebody who's 25
when somebody says when you're next to
one of your [ __ ]
and you bump into me and i got colossae
whatever the [ __ ] i drink whatever the
[ __ ] they're drinking now i'm on bellow
all right and you bump into me i'm with
maria and you bump into me i gotta say
something you know lee
no you did the right thing the other you
did one thing good and you did one thing
bad
okay
the good thing that you did is you
walked away they didn't they didn't
touch it they didn't kiss it and they
didn't squeeze it no the bad thing was
that you went anyway next time rip up
those [ __ ] tickets
you know what i'm saying because you're
a nice guy and that type of [ __ ]
will happen to a guy like you
look at that guy that's in the hospital
from the giant game
a dodger guy that went through it
you know what man i don't want to be a
part of that i know they're nice you
know what when i'm sitting with normal
people
i want to see white people around me in
that thing because that's what the
stadium has become
that's where you have to sit you can't
sit in a dog pound no more what are you
gonna wear if you wear a dodger shirt
they yell at you
if you wear you know look at this thing
in anaheim the raider fans right now
fighting the raider fans you need that
in your life
pay all that money and you can't
guarantee yourself
you don't know if you're going to make
it to the parking lot because you have a
stupid boston red side shirt on yeah
oh they saw your [ __ ] they saw your
stupid [ __ ] keychain
yeah i'm not saying you have a keychain
with you i'm just saying i don't but i
do i did wear red socks well then you
deserve to get your ass kicked
you're lucky you made it out of there
you know now i wish they would have
kicked in the stomach one time so you
would have said something kicked me in
the stomach i don't know what to do
i would have said well what's the
situation i get paul on ice cream and i
left with a [ __ ]
dodger hat on i'd say you know it tugs
heads there you're lucky who gives a
[ __ ] what they are there usually
protecting you and your girlfriend
if you would have gone with me to the
game
i don't care what you wear because the
first time you get kicked in the stomach
i'm leaving you there especially if you
wear that's what i'd say to you you wore
a stupid [ __ ] hat i'd say i'm leaving
you there dawg that's true i cheer for
the doctors but i'm not going to buy a
doctor's hat i didn't say it away then
don't wear nothing but i have to wear a
hat don't know when where [ __ ] where
like where are those white people safari
hats were they you know i'm saying white
people love that [ __ ] it's going to be
yeah with the flaps they love it they
they all they want to look weirder than
[ __ ] and show people that they want a
[ __ ] excursion where the [ __ ] they
going
it was fun though it was cool did the
dodgers win they did we actually didn't
we didn't see them when they went into
extra innings oh okay
we left after nine but it was cool it
was it was pretty cool to think about
like finn scully did it for 50 years
yeah
67
67 i think it's 67. oh wow that's
amazing whatever
i could be wrong
you're probably right you're from here
right yeah yeah so um but however long
he did it for that's pretty cool yeah
and plus
he came from brooklyn all the way to la
and he's been the man
i wanted to go to that game when's the
last time you've been to a dodger game
didn't you go a long time ago i worked
with felipe i went with my uncle i used
to go yeah you were talking about your
uncle in the story dude i found the way
to do it apollo has the way it's great
yeah i'm gonna take a bus like a [ __ ]
mental
leave me alone please you almost got
beat up with a red sox i'm gonna take
advice from you
you gave me two losers as restaurants
that [ __ ] one restaurant was so bad they
just went out of business which one
skinny deputy whatever the [ __ ] it was
that wasn't my fault they explained this
but no you told them to make it a bar
you did you went in there every day and
supported that [ __ ] and then went and
watched the [ __ ] marvel movie and
[ __ ] i'm having such a great day
i had my turkey burger what was it
what'd you eat that buffalo bison
buy some burgers but yeah good but
here's the thing you couldn't park there
so i couldn't go
that's why they went on a [ __ ]
business yeah
you're next to that diner you're next to
dominoes and starbucks
the last thing i'd eat is in that
[ __ ] place that place next to it when
they got good soup they got good soup
what is that i don't even know what that
is right next to it it's been there for
two thousand years yeah if they get
eight customers a day
they're [ __ ] good okay but they i
went there one time and it wasn't bad i
mean it wasn't [ __ ] tremendous but
the soup i didn't believe anything going
wild these people know how to make like
it was a red pepper soup oh i love soup
meat
i was watching our buddy jordan has a
vlog and i was just watching it one day
you know those sandwiches you like on
laurel canyon at that store
like halfway up a little canyon there's
like a little store
he said there's an italian restaurant
underneath have you ever been there no
no
okay what store that has sandwiches a
little candy you know ones that really
good turkey sandwiches
i don't know what place okay we talked
about it every time we drive by it but
what place on location where laurel came
in and what let's pretty much halfway
down hold on all the way to the store
on the way this all that supermarket
there yeah yeah
right down right underneath is an
italian place i heard that that's why
they got the valet parking and stuff yes
i don't know if you don't they say it's
really good yeah that's great i'll stick
to my [ __ ] spot up here it took me 20
years they got the seafood risotto they
got the seafood pasta with the red sauce
you had the bolognese did you enjoy the
bolognese oh yeah did you enjoy the
[ __ ] uh the opening dish when they
brought you the salami in the prison it
was great so why the [ __ ] would i go
down the hill with jordan peel and eat
that [ __ ] i guarantee there's a by the
way down there
but
have you tried the lasagna there yet yes
is it good [ __ ] out of this world i
haven't had lasagna in here two bites of
it steam came out of me as i get right
back to my wife i'm not gonna lose
weight not to put 82 pounds on those
plates lasagna that [ __ ] will kill you
like if you go to pop what's the name of
this dump over here pepperonis what's
this place in burbank boulevard that
you're going to get malaria if you eat
the salad
pinocchios that [ __ ] dump over there
that place is [ __ ] horrific dog
[ __ ] horrific
i've never been there i've been there
twice and both times i wanted to shoot
myself
if you're in a rush i can't lie to you
and you go in there i ain't gonna lie to
nobody you just get the spaghetti with
the [ __ ] meat sauce and run for your
life
it's not bad it's like going asbarrow
what is it called sparrow sparrow and
getting the [ __ ] spaghetti it ain't
gonna kill you it ain't the best thing
in the world but you know what things
are bad i get it you get parmesan cheese
and you pour it on there like you're the
last man that's gonna eat at that
restaurant
besides parmesan cheese got no
carbohydrates it's number flavored jack
and it fills your [ __ ] up people know
that's the cheat drug right there just
[ __ ] turn that can over like an
animal
i love parmesan i'm sure you do
[ __ ] yeah speaking of soups i got
umbondigos at my house oh
i got them from these old ladies
and it's you have the meatballs they
have the soup i got the soup and the
meatballs and they're all in there yeah
and what else is in the soup tell them
talk to me they got a little cilantro a
couple onions some avocado potato no no
avocado for but you doped avocado oh
yeah yeah you have to know what i do is
i put the avocado on the tortilla and
then i just roll it and i dip it when i
eat
jesus than your church yeah but then
you're not eating the primal diet come
on doc
i'm starting to eat the avocado forget
the [ __ ] tortilla you'd be killing it
and [ __ ] like [ __ ] tupac when they
got out of the prison
it's a double album you know what i'm
saying hell yeah no i i love that
tortilla too much dawg dawg i loved when
you were when i heard you on birch
podcast
then when i found out you were gonna be
on [ __ ] joe's and you told me i even
loved it more
you know joe wouldn't [ __ ] put you on
there unless he saw something so it's
great man that was great dude uh he late
he even let me open for him on friday at
the ice house pack sold out tremendous i
haven't i've never seen it that i've
never performed there without that pack
that clubs never gave me a night or
anything
so it was awesome rudy wasn't there in
the back
room
jumping down the back i could fill it up
like this when i had george lopez i
filled it up like this one time
yeah it was cool it was a it was a great
show he killed it too man like he killed
it he destroyed that place well
i got to say something that
first of all if you know anything about
him he's the ultimate professional
oh yeah he's the ultimate professional
and
once you see little things you're like
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
you know he has always been an ultimate
professional
and i thank him every day every time i
talk there's times i call him he goes
what's up dog i go you know what
just want to say hello i want to say
thank you man
because what you taught me i saved five
years of heartache
he teaches you
the right way on how to do economy from
traveling there with time to get there
how to do it who to say no to there was
times like why aren't you gonna do this
radio show [ __ ] no
[ __ ] them i'm not getting up at five i
would go jesus
you know everybody else does that he
would have his own reason behind it and
he believed in it 150
everything he's you know these times i
looked at him and i go this guy's a
cold-blooded [ __ ] it's business
it's business this is uh you know as
things start kicking up for you now
you'll notice that things change you
notice the [ __ ] people come out of
the back through
and you're like what the [ __ ] i did this
myself
joe rogan gives you a hole it's like
football
that's all joe rogan is joe rogan is a
[ __ ]
offensive tackle
and he opens up a hole for you and you
take that hole
and you do what you want you could
either [ __ ] go to the 20-yard line
or and get five or six yards or you
could score a touchdown
in my world
i took a couple ten yard [ __ ]
recoveries i fumbled a few times
but eventually i took that hole and i
hit a touchdown with it i found the
niche
everybody thinks that you know for a
year
everybody every comic who had been
struggling would hit me up hey how can i
get on that podcast because they thought
it was the johnny carson of today and it
really is
ari didn't get a comedy central special
all that stuff because of joe rogan joe
rogan opens the door for you
you find your niche and you tackle it
and it happens in everyday life
you're going to work one day you're a
[ __ ] mechanic's helper i come in one
day the mechanic quit
guess who's the new mechanic
and next thing you know you do
transmissions well right boom you're the
transmission [ __ ] guy i'm gonna give
you 22.50 instead of [ __ ] eight
dollars an hour and i'll give you a
[ __ ] uniform so you don't walk around
here like it's the same thing with
everything every time every once in a
while in your life bro
somebody blocks for you and puts a hole
what you do with that [ __ ] hole
that's up to you joe can't do nothing
after that he opened it for you
that podcast is so strong so many people
hear that podcast and again that podcast
is better than a movie in my eyes
i've done movies and i've gotten better
results from that [ __ ] podcast and
just going on there and talking the
truth so what do you think i should do
because you know i'm new to this like
i'm well you got 2 000 new followers
probably yeah we'll get another 5 000 in
four days
as people start downloading it and
listening to it
and now is your time now is your time to
start tweeting letting the world know
george perez okay i'm gonna start a
podcast too
whatever you want to do i'd rather you
start on social media okay
get your social media going let these
people know now they want to hear from
you they're going to ask you questions
answer their questions start booking
little dates
one nights don't expect much no i hear
you
you know it all starts with 50 75 100
150 175
you pay more attention to your social
media you again you find a niche
i'm not an instagram guy my my my
brother mikey helps me with my instagram
but i'm a twitter and a facebook guy
that's what i'm good with okay i'm not
[ __ ] harassing periscope i'll link
ending i don't want to see them again
ever again i got like three more
requests
i get one more request from link
gingding what is it lincoln then i'm
going to sue those
because they lie to people it make
people feel special we're the social
network for professionals where you are
it's the same punches on facebook why
would not gonna follow you there you
gotta follow me
you're gonna post pictures of your dog
licking your wife's face and your ugly
kids in bermuda i don't give a [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying
where you gonna be at break it down i'm
going to be at the brea improv thursday
and friday september 29th and the 30th
and thursday's at 10 o'clock show and
friday's the 9 30 show
where you got next week in the next
couple weeks you got new year's date yet
uh no i don't have a new year's day uh
in october i'm back at the
berea or i'm at the ontario improv and
then i might be going to dallas in
december what's going on down there i
don't know like this guy that books
death squad for me in redband i i think
we're gonna have like san antonio dallas
phoenix vegas and then san diego
so
just happy and going with it you know
i'm proud of you man thank you i'm proud
of a lot of these guys i came up with
but you're one of the ones i'm really
proud of i really dig we always talk
once yeah and i always love your wisdom
man you've always been the one we always
talk i always call him and check in if i
don't see him
if i see him slip and i drop a little
line and he knows what i'm talking about
i don't have to tell him he knows he
knows what we're talking about you know
he's not dumb
and i appreciate that i hate when people
play dumb with me you're one of those
dudes that you're going hey you caught
me what's up what's up
you know it's funny because i did all
that dumb [ __ ]
i did all that [ __ ] though i got away
with murder in some places they knew
when they never gave me a spot again
all right [ __ ] up [ __ ] i did dog you
know
and that's why when i pull kids over
sometimes hey listen man it's none of my
business
i don't give a [ __ ] i put one of my
buddies over i was looking at the store
like
eight months ago and this dude was doing
bumps i'm like
wow [ __ ] noticeable and i saw
the next thing i listen man
i did a bump in there every night after
i got off stage
after i got on stage i got some of that
chewy dust
and you couldn't stop being that [ __ ]
comedy store i had coke going in all
those places
i can't believe i still go down there i
don't even feel it no more when i go
down i'm gonna go on nine years without
doing culture wow that's awesome bro
that's awesome can you believe that [ __ ]
no in [ __ ] years 2007.
damn
when you got off it and then last time
were you planning on it being forever or
were you just thinking
nothing was forever in my worldly but it
just worked out i like it that way it
was at the right time
i'm the type of guy let's pretend
let's pretend you're hooked on [ __ ]
milkshakes yes and you go to [ __ ]
florida and you get caught in a [ __ ]
hurricane for two weeks
and you haven't had a milkshake and you
visibly looked at the [ __ ] scale and
you lost eight pounds
would you come back would you have a
milkshake you don't even need a
milkshake no more now
would you say to yourself i don't need a
[ __ ] milkshake i'm gonna have a
milkshake one time no
you're gonna go i'm never gonna have a
milkshake again i got off milkshakes i'm
done i'm moving forward
that's what it felt like
it wasn't that i did anything it was
like on my way through three weeks and
after three weeks from there i said
that's it yeah you're good well if i do
this it's by my doing because my body's
telling me dog what good
we're good we've had our abuse we've
taken our abuse
whatever you want to do from here on it
is good and i sat there we letting go
you know what i'm gonna give it tonight
i'm not gonna do it and i would go you
know what next friday i'm gonna do it
and all of a sudden if i got to that
friday i go am i crazy
i just got cleaned another seven days
why would i do the next one then it got
to the holidays i couldn't believe it
new year's like that day
and i remember the first time i was
sober i went up to san francisco with
red band rogan
and i remember thinking wow it's been
like 45 days
that's crazy that is
was it a like were you more focused
like just being more sober with it like
you could see [ __ ] you didn't see when
you were on it
the first year after i didn't do coke i
didn't know what i was saying george
yeah my body was getting used to [ __ ] at
so many different levels the biggest
fear i had was that i wouldn't be funny
oh that i was going to take it too
seriously and maybe get caught up with
jesus
after 45 days
i got to write
like i was like something's going on
here and then myspace was popular and i
would write a blog every monday
and from that blog it jogged my memory
to to
it really that writing i credited to
staying sober
that that [ __ ] constant give me
something to do every monday thinking of
a story and then leaving then going
that [ __ ] story wouldn't happen if it
wasn't for coke because when you think
something and you write something it's
two different [ __ ] things
when you tell her a story about you
going to jail and you write it down and
put it away and then read it tomorrow
you'll shut that [ __ ] magazine and go
what the [ __ ] was i thinking that day
when i read the land the the kidnapping
one and when i read the [ __ ]
one when i robbed mundy and all those
things i would read them two days later
and go first off
i can't believe
i told everybody on myspace and second
of all i can't believe i did that
like i don't know who that guy is
it's like i was writing a book about
somebody else
and you got a big response from it as
well right
absolutely absolutely at the same time i
worked on my writing
thing if you commit to a write once a
week
within six months on facebook you'll
have people reading your blog on mondays
and subscribing and after a year and a
half you can have ads on there and
people click
for whatever they're going to use anyway
whether it's amazon amazon you can make
a little living off your podcast off
your uh
blog and it's very interesting like i'm
thinking of doing it again like i should
have been doing it for the special
but you know what man
there's so much [ __ ] on your plate on a
daily basis
that if you're really hot like right now
i've never been this busy
like i've never been
this busy you know
writing a pilot writing a special i'm
shooting october 15th i've never had
if i would have had this special 10
years ago you know what i'd be doing
right now
telling lee i'm going to crush it
not really i'm not that type of person
i'd be telling lee i was prepared
and i'd go up daily and do five minutes
and improvise the rest
and i wouldn't care where i ended i
can't do this this time
it's weird when things get presented to
you at the point of your life where
you're at
if i would have got this 10 years ago i
would have done that would have snorted
that [ __ ] down payment
[ __ ] i would like i did piazzo yeah but
he also was a joke to me i thought first
of all i didn't think i was gonna get
picked up you killed it though but i
killed it if you watch it now i didn't
kill it i was just a [ __ ] dude dying
up there telling knock knock jokes
to those [ __ ] savages that were in
the audience
i don't know what no i didn't even get
laughs they had to put tape in there and
[ __ ] i hit those people too hard they
weren't ready for that [ __ ]
even even those people laughed montoya
and his partner were in the background
some of those people were petrified i
didn't give a [ __ ]
you know what i gave a [ __ ] about was
that cash and driving back remember i
didn't stay that night yeah i remember
you like i'm out here where's my check i
taped got in that car
and i already had the eight ball waiting
for me on hold to the next day i was
gonna pay him because i had to get my
wife to check the cashier and she was
already gonna give me 508 ball would be
paid for damn remember i gave my room
key to david yeah
i didn't stay i taped it was
thanksgiving week the friday after
thanksgiving
2008 no no no no it's 2006. i got locked
up that year wow so it was we taped that
november of 2016. and i got i got locked
up the day after felipe's birthday
because we were at the sunset room for
his birthday on monday then i went to
court tuesday that's when i got locked
up i think it's
ah
june 16th
and now you're in jail watching piazzo
comedy slam with the index and then
going that ain't you fool yeah
yeah
yeah it's very wild
you know brother it's been an
interesting ride for the both of us i'm
very happy that we're still doing our
thing
we're not in trouble we overcame
whatever ghost was wanting us to
put us in those predicaments and here we
are brother it's a new life so thank you
thank you for coming on the show thank
you brother thank you i'm gonna be at
the ice house wednesday night
ten dollar show and still no
expectations
i got a solid 40. i need to come up with
another 20 so i'm going to work some
[ __ ] out on you savages
and then i'm at the columbus
[ __ ] funny bone
october 6th through the 9th or something
like that
it's that week all right just check it
out get tickets whatever the [ __ ] you
need to do you know i love columbus i'm
excited about going playing tickets
every night man to [ __ ] get there
it's a nightmare
no direct flights coming back
it's a [ __ ] night man it's a
nightmare on elm street like paul mooney
said but that ain't stopping me
[ __ ] number one i want to thank
our sponsor for the show the one and
only the most powerful supplement out
there on it
my people had one of those [ __ ]
shakes today i was gone and i wanted to
put all that protein back in my system
so this morning i had my little fruit
smoothie and about 10 o'clock before i
took mercy to the park
i blasted some [ __ ] nice little
chocolate with water
and uh you know what it kept me alive
until i ate with lee over at the mexican
joint
because i had to go to tacos yeah good
potato tacos then my wife made a little
pot roast i didn't eat the noodles i
just need the beef with a couple
potatoes
and now i'm here with you [ __ ]
but anyway back to honda.com the
milkshakes
the strongbone the shroomtex sport
you know the the alpha brain which i
take the powder every time i fly when i
get home and before i get on the [ __ ]
plane so i don't get my jet lag listen
anything i take from them is solid as
[ __ ] gold do you want me to sit here
and tell you what's in those things i
can't do that i'm not gonna lie to you
but do me a favor go to audit.com right
now go to on it look at the great list
of supplements look what they got in
them look at the testimonials look at
the videos look at the supplements look
at the weights they have and all the
workout stuff and you take your pick as
far as weights are concerned i can't
help you supplements i get you 10 off go
read you find something you like go to
the box and press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h and i'm going to give you a
10 off all right that's how the [ __ ] i
wrote
i just got my new uh tellingly what we
got in the mail oh
tushies we got the tushies so we're
going to hook them up this week oh my
god and let you [ __ ] know it's
crackalackin
lee's gonna have a full report for you
it's been a hundred degrees i need it so
bad yeah your ass is all dirty and fungi
and [ __ ] oh that's how the bacteria sits
around your ring worm this is the
ultimate test if this is it if the
turtle can withstand this
it could be just for you because you're
a disgusting animal you eat that lizard
you gotta get a toothbrush okay and as
the water hits your [ __ ] toothbrush
your [ __ ] you want to shine it up a
point should i go like a sonicare level
or just like the regulator
you'll break it with that [ __ ]
hemorrhoid you're growing down there all
you hear is this and you electrocute
yourself and then i gotta call your mom
and the insurance people and the jewish
time
to try to sue tuffy or whatever the [ __ ]
it is and whatever just get yourself a
plane the oral will be
right
a little beginner like for a
six-year-old oh you don't scrape up your
[ __ ] too bad and start with can't be
the one that like has a song that plays
no no listen don't get cute with your
uncle joey just
you want to clean that muffler i can't
imagine what you got in there i don't
want to complete for a week just do like
a cleanse
like banana juice with pineapples and
[ __ ] see what happens with that when
i do that you get skinny you look good
yeah but i get
you you say i'm gonna pass out that's
okay i'd rather you pass out than carry
eight pounds like goat [ __ ] you eat
you know carnitas here [ __ ] tacos
there you don't know these people
you eat that [ __ ] me you don't know
these people you're eating that [ __ ]
and the next thing you know that [ __ ]
sits in your bowels
you know you have a pound of meat dead
meat sitting in your bowels taco bell
and all that [ __ ]
it came out when you did the cleanse the
first time
but now it just sits there me too i
can't i got the same meat in my nutsack
there that steak i ate at [ __ ] that
hospital at the hotel or the airport
that's sitting in my gut that's why i
ate that fruit smoothie twice because
i'm trying to get all that dead horse
meat out of there the orange cream was
good the orange cream yeah it was
tremendous they took good care of you
i love your [ __ ] sucker i'm just looking
at you [ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't do
kettlebells today you're slipping no
i'll do them tomorrow you call dave call
you back no i'm gonna have to call him
today i i haven't called him one of them
we didn't call him either that's what
i'm saying yeah i call him every day so
he gets the gym open yeah like [ __ ]
around this is what we teach you call
him every day till he calls you back
george perez hope good luck on thursday
and friday thank you
if you tweet i'll be tweeting for you
we'll be back thursday afternoon
[ __ ] i love you guys have a great
week
that's all we got for you stay black
you